UNABLE TO ATTEND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO RESOLVE THAT TO SEE
IF THERE'S REPLACEMENT WITNESS
BUT WE WILL BEGIN. VERY SOON.
YES PLEASE PLEASE PUT IT TO.
GOOD MORNING APOLOGIES FOR A
DELAY WE AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
WELL FIRST WE ARE NOW BEGINNING
THE JOINT SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES ON PUBLIC SAFETY
HEARING ON A PROPOSED
INITIATIVE- WHICH ON THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WEBSITE IS
REFERRED TO AS INITIATIVE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN FORTY THAT DOES
NOT MEAN THAT'S THE PROPOSITION.
THREE TWO CALL IN THIS CASE. NO
NO OKAY GOOD ALL RIGHT SO
ANYWAY THE ARMS PURPOSE OF OUR
GATHERING IS FOR THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE TO HAVE THAT HEARING-
THE REASON THAT WE WERE TAKING
SOME TIME BEFORE I GAVEL DOWN
WAS BECAUSE THE MAIN WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSITION-
FROM FROM HIM SHE KNIGHTED
CALLED US AND INSULAR IN IL
TOOK A CHANCE WE WANTED TO DO
OUR BEST TO TRY TO FIND SOMEONE
TO REPRESENT. IF WE'VE NOT YET
BEEN SICK BUT WE AT LEAST WE'LL
HEAR FROM OUR LEDGE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND SOME OTHERS AND
PERHAPS BEFORE WE ARE ADJOURNED
WE WILL HAVE SOMEONE WHO COMES
AND REPRESENTS THE INITIATIVE-
LET ME STOP THERE AND ALLOW ME
TO TURN. TO MY- FELLOW CHAIR
AND THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REGGIE SEVEN STORE JONES SAWYER
IN BY YOU JONES SAWYER YES.
GOOD MORNING- THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER FOR INVITING ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE- TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. AS WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED THE PURPOSE
OF THIS HEARING IS TO LISTEN TO
THE POLICY CONSIDERATIONS
REGARDING THE BALLOT MEASURE
THAT PROPOSES TO MAKE CHANGES
TO PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN AND
FIFTY SEVEN. TO THE- ROOM
JUSTICE RELY. STILL CALIFORNIA
MUST CONTINUE WORK TO DO WE DO
TO PRE POPULATION REALLY IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THE
FEDERAL MANDATE THAT DEEMED ARE
OVERCROWDED SYSTEM ON
CONSTITUTIONAL. WITHOUT
REDUCTIONS TO IN MAY POPULATION
SPENDING AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN IT IS TODAY AND CALIFORNIA
WOULD ULTIMATELY BE REQUIRED TO
BUILD NEW PRISONS OR CONTRACT
FOR MORE PRISON BEDS. THESE ARE
STEP THAT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEES. AND THIS
LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE HAVE
TRIED TO INVOKE AVOID IN FACT
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
REHABILITATION AS THE ULTIMATE
GOAL TO REDUCING PRISON
POPULATION AS WITH OTHER
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS WE WILL
NOT BE TAKING A BOAT ON
ANYTHING TODAY. THIS HEARING
WILL BEGIN WITH A REPORT FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND THEY WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY STATEMENTS FROM
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE
TAKEN AN INTEREST IN HIS BALLOT
MEASURE. PLEASE KEEP IN MIND.
THE TO REPRESENTATION THE LA L.
ARE NEUTRAL. SAY THAT AGAIN
THEY ARE NEUTRAL AND THEY WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO ANSWER SOME TO
POLICY QUESTIONS QUESTIONS OF
THAT NATURE BEST RESERVED FOR
THE OTHER PANELISTS. AT THE END
OF THE HEARING THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME OF I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO MIGHT LIKE TO MAKE
SOME OPENING REMARKS TO DO SO.
SENATOR JACKSON THANK YOU YEAH.
IT WAS MY HOPE AND I HOPE WE
CAN HEAR REASONS- WIDE. THESE
INITIATIVES SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED. GIVEN WHAT I BELIEVE
THE STATISTICS ARE IN HOW WE'RE
SEEING CRIME AT ITS LOWEST
LEVEL. IN DECADES AND SO I HOPE
THAT THAT WILL BE SOME OF THE
FOCUS HERE- WHAT IS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
ESSENTIALLY. I'M DOING
WEAKENING OF THOSE PUBLICLY
APPROVED PROVISIONS UNDER FORTY
SEVEN AND FIFTY SEVEN AND THEN
THE OTHER INITIATIVES THAT
WE'VE HAD TO TRY TO REFOCUS OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM MORE IN
PREVENTION AND REHABILITATION
SO- I THINK THAT FOR MANY OF US
WHO WILL BE VOTING ON THIS
INITIATIVE THAT IS REALLY A
CRITICAL QUESTION I HOPE THAT
THAT CAN BE. DISCUSSED TODAY
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME SO
JUST AS A CLARIFICATION THIS
IT'S A SINGLE INITIATIVE AND
WE'RE HAVING THE HEARING ON THE
SINGLE INITIATIVE AND AS I
INDICATED BEFORE BECAUSE IT IS
SCHEDULED TO BE ON THE NOVEMBER
BALLOT WE DO NOT HAVE A
PROPOSITION NUMBER YET BUT ON
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
WEBSITE IT IS REFERRED TO AS A
INITIATIVE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
FORTY SOON AS MY COLLEAGUES
HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER- INDICATED AT THE END OF
THE FORMAL PRESENTATIONS WE
WIL HAVE- PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE MIKE OVER THERE SO WE'LL
START NOW WITH- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE HAVE
BOTH CAITLYN O'NEILL UNTRUE SIR
BURKE 52% ON THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- ANALYSIS OF
THE INITIATIVE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING. CAITLYN O'NEILL WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'M GOING TO BE SPEAKING
TODAY FROM A HANDOUT WHICH IS
BEING PASSED OUT. TO YOU ALL
STATE LAW REQUIRES OUR OFFICE
TO PREPARE IMPARTIAL ANALYSES
OF ALL MEASURES THAT QUALIFY
FOR THE STATEWIDE BALLOT TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDE WE ARE
CURRENTLY PREPARING OUR
MATERIALS FOR THIS MEASURE.
TODAY I'M GOING TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE MEASURE AND
DISCUSS THE MAJOR FISCAL FAX.
TURNING TO PAGE ONE THE MEASURE
ED MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES TO
STATE LAW- THAT CAN GENERALLY
BE GROUPED INTO FOUR CATEGORIES
WHICH ARE ONE INCREASING FOR
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR CERTAIN
THEFT RELATED CRIMES TO
CHANGING HOW OFFENDERS ARE
SUPERVISED IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THREE THREE CHANGING THE
PROCESS CREATED BY PROPOSITION
FIFTY SEVEN WHICH WAS APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. FOR CONSIDERING THE
RELEASE OF CERTAIN OFFENDERS
FROM PRISON. AND FOR REQUIRING
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO COLLECT DNA
SAMPLES FROM ADULTS CONVICTED
OF CERTAIN OFFENSES. OVER THE
NEXT- FEW PAGES OF THIS HANDOUT
I'M GONNA PROVIDE FIRST SOME
BACKGROUND AND THEN DISCUSS THE
CHECK CHANGES AT THE WOOD THE
MEASURE WOULD MAKE ON EACH OF
THOSE FOUR CATEGORIES AND THEN
I'M GOING TO DESCRIBE THE MAJOR
FISCAL FACTS OF THE MEASURE. ON
PAGE TWO I'M GOING TO PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
CRIMINAL SENTENCING OFFENDERS
CONVICTED OF FELONIES CAN BE
SPARSE GEN CAN BE SENTENCED A
STATE PRISON IF THEY HAVE.
CURRENT OR PRIOR CONVICTIONS
FOR SERIOUS VIOLENT OR SEX
OFFENSES. WHERE IS FELONY
OFFENDERS WITH OUT THOSE KERNER
PRIOR CONVICTIONS ARE
GENERALLY- SENTENCED OR
TYPICALLY SENTENCED TO COUNTY
JAIL OR THE SUPERVISION OF A
COUNTY PROBATION OFFICER OR
SOME COMBINATION OF THE TWO.
AND THEN DEPENDING ON THE
DISCRETION OF THE JUDGE AND THE
CRIME COMMITTED OFFENDERS WITH
CURRENT US AT OR PRIOR SEARS
VIOLIN OR SEX OFFENSES CAN BE
KEPT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND
THEN OFFENDERS CONVICTED OF
MISDEMEANORS I HAVE MAY BE
SENTENCED TO JAIL. COUNTY
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION OR IF I
RECEIVE A FINE OR SOME
COMBINATION OF THOSE. AND
MISDEMEANOR OFFENDERS GENERALLY
RECEIVE A LESSER AMOUNTS OF
TIME IN JAIL AND UNDER
SUPERVISION RELATIVE TO FELONY
OFFENDERS. I AND FINALLY SOME
CRIMES CAN BE CHARGES EITHER A
FELONY OR MISDEMEANOR AND THOSE
CRIMES ARE REFERRED TO AS
WYLER'S. TURNING TO PAGE THREE
THE MEASURE WOULD INCREASE
PENALTIES FOR CERTAIN THE LATED
CRIMES BY CREATING TWO NEW
WIDLAR CRIMES MEANING THAT THEY
WOULD BE PUNISHABLE AS A FELONY
OR MISDEMEANOR AND IF
PUNISHABLE AS A FELONY BY UP TO
THREE YEARS IN JAIL INCLUDING
IN CASES WHERE THE PERSON HAS A
PRIOR- CURRENT OR PRIOR SERIES
OF. VIOLENT OR SEX OFFENSE. THE
FIRST OF THOSE CRIMES WOULD BE
CALLED SERIAL SAFT. WOULD APPLY
TO ANY PERSON MATURE MORE PAST
CONVICTIONS FOR CERTAIN DEATH
RELATED CRIMES. WHO IS FOUND
GUILTY OF SHOPLIFTING OR PETY
THEFT INVOLVING PROPERTY WORTH
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS. THE SECOND OF THOSE
CRIMES IS CALLED ORGANIZE
RETAIL THEFT IT WOULD APPLY TO
ANY PERSON ACTING WITH OTHERS.
THE COMMITTEE NEEDS AFTER
SHOPLIFTING TOUR MORE TIMES.
WHERE THE TOTAL VALUE OF
PROPERTY STOLEN EXCEEDS APPLE
WITHIN A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS EXCEEDS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS. AND THEN I'D NOTE THAT
THERE IS A SIMILAR CRIME A
CURRENTLY IN STATE LAW- THE
TIME PERIOD FOR AGGREGATING
THE- THE CRIMES IS- IS TWELVE
MONTHS BUT THE DOLLAR OF VALUE.
THRESHOLD IS HIGHER IT'S NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS AND THAT
CRIME IS WILL SUNSET UNDER
EXISTING LAW A FEW MONTHS AFTER
THE MEASURE WOULD GO INTO
EFFECT IF IT'S APPROVED. THE
MEASURE ALSO ALLOWS SOME EXIST
SOME EXISTING THEFT RELATED
OFFENSES IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES TO BE PUNISHED-
AS FELONIES INSTEAD OF
MISDEMEANORS. TURNING TO PAGE
FOR. A OFFENDERS WHO WERE
RELEASED FROM PRISON AFTER
SERVING A SENTENCE FOR A
SERIOUS OR VIOLENT FELONY ARE
SUPERVISED AT A IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
BY STATE PAROLE AGENTS WORDS
OFFENDERS RELEASED FROM PRISON
FOR. NON SERIOUS NONVIOLENT
OFFENSES ARE GENERALLY
SUPERVISED BY COUNTY PROBATION
OFFICERS ON WHAT'S CALLED POST
RELEASE COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
OR APPEAR CS FOR SHORT. AND
WHEN THOSE OFFENDERS BREAK THE
RULES THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
FOLLOW AS- WHILE THEY'RE UNDER
SUPERVISION REFERRED TO AS THE
TERMS OF THEIR SUPERVISION. A
PAROLE AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS CAN REQUEST A JUDGE
TO CHANGE THE TERMS OF AN
OFFENDER'S SUPERVISION WHICH
CAN RESULT IN HARSHER TERMS OR
AT THAT PERIOD IN JAIL. THE
MEASURE WOULD MAKE VARIOUS
CHANGES THAT AFFECT HOW PAROLE
AND PROBATION DEPARTMENT
SUPERVISE OFFENDERS INCLUDING
REQUIRING THAT AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO PETITION A JUDGE
TO CHANGE THE TERMS OF A P. R.
C. S. OFFENDERS. SUPERVISION
IF- THEY VIOLATE THEIR TERMS
FOR A THIRD TIME. AND REQUIRING
STATE PAROLE IN COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
EXCHANGE MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE FENDERS THEY SUPERVISE.
MOVING ON TO SOME BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON THE PROPOSITION
FIFTY SEVEN RELEASE
CONSIDERATION PROCESS. THAT
MEASURE AMENDED THE STATE
CONSTITUTION TO SPECIFY THAT
PRISON INMATES CONVICTED OF
NONVIOLENT CRIMES WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE
CONSIDERATION AFTER COMPLETING
THE DEAD TERM FOR THEIR PRIMARY
OFFENSE. CDC ARE THEN ADOPTED
REGULATIONS THAT. LIMIT THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT PROCESS-
NOTABLY- TO. DOES NOT CONVICTED
OF IT- NOT SERVING A TERM FOR A
VIOLENT FELONY- AS WELL AS
THOSE NOT REQUIRED TO REGISTER
AS A SEX OFFENDER. BPH STAFF OR
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS STAFF
REVIEW OF INFORMATION ABOUT
HELD ELIGIBLE INMATE SUCH AS
THEIR CRIMINAL HISTORY TO
DETERMINE IF THEY DO NOT POSE
AN UNREASONABLE RISK TO PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ARE SUITABLE FOR
RELEASE. THIS MEASURE WOULD
MAKE VARIOUS CHANGES TO THAT
PROCESS- INCLUDING EXCLUDING IT
CERTAIN INMATES WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE. FOR
EXAMPLE I THOSE WHO ARE
SENTENCED TO LIFE WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE- UNDER THE MEASURE
THAT WOULD- TYPICALLY APPLIED
TO A NON VIOLENT THIRD STRIKERS
THE MEASURE WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS TO
DENY RELEASE TO INMATES WHO
POSE AN UNREASONABLE RISK OF
CREATING VICTIMS AS A RESULT OF
FUTURE FELONY ACTIVITY RATHER
THAN. THOSE WHO POSE AN
UNREASONABLE RISK TO PUBLIC
SAFETY SO THERE'S A CHANGE IN
THE RELEASE STANDARD- AND THEN
IT IT WOULD REQUIRE CITIES ARE
TO MAKE REASONABLE EFFORTS TO
LOCATE VICTIMS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE REGISTERED WITH THE
STATE. AND THEN I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THIS MEASURES SEEK TO
PUT LIMITS ON CD SERWIS
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY-
WITHOUT CHANGING THE
CONSTITUTION- SO IF CHALLENGE
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT A JUDGE
COULD RULE THAT THOSE
PROVISIONS AS RELATE TO WHAT
CONSTITUTES WHAT SEAT AT
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN PUT IN
THE CONSTITUTION- AND WHAT THE
MEASURE SEEKS TO CHANGE- MISSED
MIGHT NOT GOING TO AFFECT. AND
THEN MOVING ON TO PAGE SIX JUST
SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND ON DNA
COLLECTION. UNDER CURRENT LAW
ANY ADULT ARRESTED. OR CHARGED
WITH A FELONY ANY JUVENILE
SOUND OF COMMITTED A FELONY OR
AN INDIVIDUAL REQUIRED TO
REGISTER AS A SEX OFFENDER
ARSONIST IS REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
A DNA SAMPLE FOR LAWN FIRST
FORSMAN PURPOSES. THOSE SAMPLES
ARE COLLECTED BY STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROCESSED- GENERALLY IN. BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND LOCAL FORENSIC
LABORATORIES. THE MEASURE WOULD
EXPANDED THAT SET OF OFFENDERS
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT ARE
REQUIRED TO COLLECT SAMPLES
FROM. A SPECIFICALLY AT WOULD
EXPAND IT TO ADULTS CONVICTED
OF CERTAIN MISDEMEANORS
INCLUDING- SHOPLIFTING FORGING
CHECKS AND CERTAIN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OFFENSES. AND FINALLY
ON PAGE SEVEN OF THIS GUIDE THE
MAJOR FISCAL FACTS OF THE
MEASURE. IT WOULD INCREASE
STATE AND LOCAL CORRECTIONS
COSTS PRIMARILY IN THREE WAYS.
FIRST IT WOULD INCREASE THE
COUNTY JAIL POPULATIONS. AND
THE LEVEL OF COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION FOR CERTAIN
OFFENDERS. SECOND WOULD LIKELY-
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF INMATES
WERE RELEASED UNDER THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN RELEASE
CONSIDERATION PROCESS AND THREE
IT WHICH- BY CHANGING COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION PRACTICES THAT
COULD ALSO INCREASE COUNTY JAIL
POPULATIONS. AND THEN WE KNOW
THAT A SMALL PORTION OF THESE
INCREASE COSTS WILL- WOULD
LIKELY BE OFFSET BY SOME REDUCE
COSTS FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS HAVING
FEWER OFFENDERS TO CONSIDER FOR
RELEASED BECAUSE OF THE-
TIGHTER EXCLUSIONARY CRITERIA
THEY WOULD HAVE. SOME REDUCE
WORKLOAD. WE ALSO KNOW THE
MEASURE COULD INCREASE STATE
AND LOCAL COURT RELATED COSTS
BY. SHIFTING INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF FELONIES REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF MISDEMEANORS. AND
MISDEMEANORS ARE EIGHTEEN
FELONIES ARE MORE EXPENSIVE FOR
COURT A HIGH COURT OPERATIONS
AND THEN- IT WOULD ALSO
INCREASE COURT PROCEEDINGS BY
REQUIRING PROBATION DEPARTMENT
MEANT STEPS- PETITION A COURT
TO CHANGE OFENDERS. CS
OFFENDERS TERMS WHEN THEY
VIOLATE FOR A THIRD TIME. AND
FINALLY THE MEASURE WOULD
INCREASE STATE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT COSTS. ASSOCIATED
WITH COLLECTING AND PROCESSING
THE ADDITIONAL DNA SAMPLES. AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. MR
SODERBERGH DID YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING BEFOREWE- ASKED FOR
QUESTIONS FROM THE DICE.
RESERVE OR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M JUST HERE
TO ASSIST WITH ANY QUESTIONS
NECESSARY THANK YOU TO
APPRECIATE IT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION. I MEAN I JUST STARTED
OFF ON YOUR OWN ON A MAJOR
FISCAL EFFECTS INSISTED ON
BUDGET. ARM SUB FIVE DO YOU
HAVE ANY BALLPARK NUMBERS OF
WHAT THAT YOU KNOW YOU SAY IT'S
GOING TO INCREASE COSTS. BUT IT
IS ONLY LIKE TWO DOLLARS STEP
WOULD MEAN ANYTHING. FIVE IS
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT COULD
BE SIGNIFICANT DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT KIND OF BALLPARK
LOOKING AT. POTENTIALLY LOOK AT.
SO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHEN WE
PREPARED- OUR LETTER ON THIS
MEASURE BEFORE IT WENT OUT FOR
SIGNATURE COLLECTION WE DID
PREPARE FISCAL ESTIMATE WHICH I
CAN SHARE WITH YOU. ALTHOUGH I
WOULD NOTE THAT- IT'S BEEN. A
COUPLE YEARS NOW SO THINGS HAVE
CHANGED. A BIG BIG ITEM
POTENTIALLY IS THAT- WHEN WE
PREPARED THE LETTER THE- THE
CDC ARE REGULATIONS ON-
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN RELEASE
CONSIDERATION ELIGIBILITY
EXCLUDED- INDEED L. LIFERS AND
NOW BECAUSE OF A COURT CASE
THEY- INCLUDE LIFERS SO. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WORK THROUGH ALL
THAT AND DO IN YOU KNOW REVISIT
EVERYTHING BUT- AT THE TIME TO
ME IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
ESTIMATED THAT- THE STATE AND
LOCAL CORRECTIONS COSTS. COULD
THERE COULD BE A NET INCREASE
IN STATE LOCAL CORRECTIONS
COSTS RANGING POTENTIALLY IN
THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AT FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE MEASURE- AND THEN WE
ESTIMATED THAT THE INCREASE IN
COURT RELATED COSTS COULD BE
AROUND A FEW MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY AND THE STATE AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT COSTS
WOULD LIKELY NOT EXCEED A
COUPLE MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
OKAY AD THEN. ON THE ON THE
PROPOSED DURING PROPOSALS- DEBT
HAVE INCREASED PENALTIES FOR
LOCAL. FOR LOCAL THIRTY VIEW AN
OBVIOUSLY THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
DEATH IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE-
SINCE I WROTE IT- DO YOU HAVE
YOU HAD ANY. DISCUSSION WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT OTHERS ABOUT
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF EVEN THE
SERIAL THAT FOR ANY OF THESE.
SPECIFICALLY HOW THEY'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED OR IS IT BOILS
THINGS WE NEED TO GET MORE
PEOPLE OUT THERE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT MAYBE THESE LAWS CAN HELP.
WITH SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
ARE THAT ARE BEING ATTRIBUTED
IN THE COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW OR
DO WE- KNOW ORGANIZED RETAIL
THAT JUST MAY BE TOO BORING
MAYBE CALL IT J. SORT JONES
SAWYER ORGANIZED RETAIL STEPPED
IN. TWO LITTLE PUNCTURE
SOMETHING. AT SO WHAT AT THE
TIME WE PREPARED OUR OUR
LETTER. WE THE ORGANIZE RETAIL
THEFT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
THAT'S CURRENTLY PART OF STATE
LAW- WITH DID NOT EXIST YET SO
WE HADN'T HAD THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE WILL BE AS WE-
WORK THIS SPRING ON PREPARING
OUR BALLOT MATERIALS WE WILL BE
HAVING THOSE TYPES OF CONCERT
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU.
CENTER MORE LOCKED Q. MADAM
CHAIR IS THERE A CORRELATION
WITH AB ONE OH NINE AND PROP
FIFTY SEVEN BECAUSE WHEN WE
STARTED THE MEETING THE CHAIR
REGINALD JONES SAWYER MENTION
HAVING TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION WHICH WAS. SORT OF
DONE BY AB ONE OH NINE. BOTH
THROUGH A REALIGNMENT AND
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN HAVE
REDUCE THE PRISON POPULATION.
DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
I JUST WANNA GO TO THAT- I WAS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN TWENTY TWELVE
FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE AND-
THE- YEAH I WAS VISITED BY
CELEBRITIES- LIKE REGINALD
JONES SAWYER. BUT I WAS INVITED
TO GO TO LOS ANGELES I THINK IT
WAS THE CALIFORNIA CLUB. BY
GOVERNOR'S. DAVIS WILSON AND
TOOK MEIJIN AND THEY WANTED TO
KNOW HOUSE AB ONE OH NINE
WORKING IN OUR COUNTIES AND
THEY INVITED THE CHAIRS OF ALL
THE COUNTIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SEVEN YEARS OFFICE
HE WAS THERE- AND BRAD METS AND
FELT CHAIR OF THE SAN MARINO
COUNTY. FORTY SUPERVISOR SAID
THAT. SINCE AB ONE OH NINE WAS
IMPLEMENTED. THE LOOKING FOR
THE WORD- PROPERTY CRIMES
PROPERTY COMES WITH A 30% AND
BILL HORN FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
STARTED NAMING THE WOMEN THAT
HAVE BEEN MURDERED. BY THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN RELEASED IN HIS
DISTRICT AND SO WE ALL HAD
STORIES OF HOW. ONE OH NINE WAS
IMPACTING A SO I DON'T SEE IN
YOUR REPORT WHICH GOT IT THIS
MORNING BUT I DON'T SEE LIKE AN
ANALYSIS OF. CRIME RATES WE
HEARD THAT IT'S GOING DOWN- BUT
IN YOUR REPORT DID YOU. DO ANY
ANALYSIS OF WHAT AT A MOMENT IN
TIME WHEN AB ONE ON NINE PROP
47-57. STARTED TO BE EFFECTIVE
WAS THERE A CHANGE BECAUSE I'M
GETTING. TARGET COMING INTO MY
OFFICE AND THEY'RE SAYING HEY
LOOK- THE SHOPLIFTING IS JUST
REALLY INCREASED. BUT I GET THE
SENSE THAT POLICE OFFICERS
AREN'T EVEN. CHARGING ANY YOU
KNOW INDIVIDUALS ANYMORE
BECAUSE THEY CAN GO UP TO NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS. THEY
THEY THEY CITE THEM THEY'RE
THEY'RE BACK THAT AFTERNOON I'M
GETTING ALL THESE ANECDOTAL
STORIES I'D- LOVE TO SEE. WHAT
THE DATA IS SHOWING BUT YOU
WON'T HAVE DAD IF PEOPLE HAVE
GIVEN UP IF PUBLIC SAFETY IS.
KIND OF THROWN THEIR HANDS UP.
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS LOOKED AT THAT
QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
REALIGNMENT AND PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN. AND THEY FOUND
THAT IN THE CASE OF
REALIGNMENT- AT CERTAIN
PROPERTY CRIMES SPECIFICALLY
AUTO THEFT DID INCREASE
SOMEWHAT- OR AT LEAST WORK THEY
WERE ABLE TO ATTRIBUTE THAT
STATISTICALLY TO. REALIGNMENT
THEY DIDN'T FIND AN INCREASE IN
VIOLENT CRIMES AND THEN-
REGARDING PROP FORTY SEVEN THEY
FOUND A- INCREASE AT. A SMALL
INCREASE IN LARCENY. I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY RESEARCHERS HAVING
YET LOOKED AT PROPOSITION FIFTY
SEVEN IN THAT WAY- IT MAY BE
THAT IT'S TOO EARLY. OKAY I'M
I'M ARGUE EVEN SEEING. NEWS
REPORTS ABOUT CITY SAN
FRANCISCO HAVING CARS WINDOWS
BROKEN AT A RATHER SUBSTANTIAL
HIGHER RATE I MEAN IT'S MAKING
IT TO. OUR OUR NEWS STATIONS
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS
A IS THERE ANYONE THAT BESIDES
PP I SEE THAT'S KIND OF DONE A
DEEPER DIVE IN SOME OF THE
STATISTICS OF CERTAIN TYPES OF
CRIMES. I AM AWARE OF A STUDY
AT BEING A UC IRVINE ON
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN DAYS
THEY FOUND- VERY SIMILAR.
RESULTS TWO PP I SEE. I'M NOT
AWARE OF OTHER STUDIES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SISTER. AS CHAIR.
SENATOR JACKSON GO AHEAD VERY
BRIEFLY I THINK WHAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT HERE IS TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE TRENDS ARE. ARE WE
SEEING REDUCTION IN CRIME.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE WAS
OR THERE HAVE BEEN CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
THE CRIMES GOING RAMP AND SO
FORTH BUT THE DATA SEEMS TO
SHOW TO THE CONTRARY AND I
THINK. PART OF THE MOTIVATION
FOR THIS INITIATIVE IS THE
BELIEF THAT CRIME IS GOING UP
AND SO I THINK WHAT REALLY IS
IMPORTANT IN TRYING TO
DETERMINE THE EFFICACY OR THE
ACCURACY OF REASON THE
MOTIVATION FOR THIS. IS WHETHER
OR NOT WE ARE SEEING CRIME
GOING UP OR CRIME IS GOING
DOWN. AND I THINK THAT IS SORT
OF THE SINGULAR ISSUE HERE ARE
AT IS AGAIN OR THE INITIATIVE
SO WE PASSED TO REFORM THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE
THEY WORKING OR NOT. AND IT'S
MY HOPE THAT WE CAN GET A AN
HONEST STRAIGHTFORWARD. IN FACT
BASED DETERMINATION OF THAT IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON OR COULD YOU
CITE US WHAT STUDIES YOU'VE
LOOKED AT THAT WAS MENTIONED
THE PP I SEE- AND THE SECOND
ONE THAT JUSTICE INVADED ME.
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT WE
FIND OUT JUST WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE WORLD
TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT AN
INITIATIVE LIKE THIS IS HELPFUL
OR HARMFUL. HAVE THIS THE
SECOND CITY WAS UC IRVINE. AND
AT. CRIME IS AT A HISTORICAL
LOW OVERALL- WE HAVE SEENIN
RECENT YEARS SORT OF A SMALL IT
TAKES ARE DOWN TAKES IN
DIFFERENT WHETHER TALKING
ABOUT- PROPERTY CRIME A VIOLENT
CRIME THE ANSWER CAN BE
DIFFERENT- IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE DONE TO DO IT AS IN
DEPTH STATISTICAL CAUSAL
ANALYSIS OF THE EFFECTS OF
THESE INITIATIVES ON CRIME
RATES. YOU SEE HAS BEEN PLAYING
THAT ROLE- THING. I ACTUALLY
HAVE THE PP I SEE REPORT BEFORE
ME- IN YOU MAY CONTINUE MR
SERVER BUT JUST TO CLARIFY I'M
LOOKING AT THE REPORT GOT THE
GRAPH RIGHT HERE. BOTH PROPERTY
CRIME RATES AND VIOLENT CRIME
RATES ARE LOWER THEY'RE NOT
HIGHER AND IN FACT THE PRICE
THEY ARE AT HISTORIC LOWS IN
THIS IS RIGHT IN THE PP I SEIZE
REPORT. YEAH WELL NOT ACCORDING
TO THIS REPORT BUT THE MAYBE
THERE'S NEW DATA BUT WE'VE NOT
SEEN IT AND NEITHER REALLY- NOR
PP I SEE IS PRESENTED IT. BUT I
WILL ALLOW YOU TO FINISH AND
THEN I'LL GO TO. MY QUESTIONS
GO AHEAD. YEAH THE ONLY THING I
WAS GOING TO- PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION AND IS THE P. P.
I. C. STUDIES THAT DID FIND.
SOME POTENTIAL INCREASE IN
PROPERTY CRIMES ESSENTIALLY THE
METHODOLOGY THIS STUDY WAS. TO
TRY TO CREATE A SYNTHETIC
CONTROL GROUP SO WHAT THEY DID
IS THEY LOOKED AT CRIME RATES
IN OTHER STATES AND SORT OF.
TURN THEM INTO A- A PACKAGE.
THAT HAD FOLLOWED CALIFORNIA
CRIME RATES CONSISTENTLY- IN
PAST YEARS. AND BY TAKING THIS
APPROACH THEY WERE ABLE TO-
MAKE A STATISTICAL ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKELY
TO HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA HAD.
PROP FORTY SEVEN AND
REALIGNMENT NOT BEEN
IMPLEMENTED. AND WHAT THEY
FOUND IS THAT- IN THE CASE OF
BOTH PROP FORTY SEVEN AND
REALIGNMENT- IT DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT THEY REALLY CONTRIBUTED
SIGNIFICANTLY TO- MAJOR
INCREASES IN CRIME AT ALL- THAT
MOST CRIME RATES WERE
UNAFFECTED BY THE MEASURES
HOWEVER IN THE CASE OF PROP
FORTY SEVEN. THEY DID THINK
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT IT
CONTRIBUTED TO SOMEWHAT OF AN
INCREASE AND LARCENY THEFT
CRIMES AND IN THE CASE OF AB
ONE OH NINE. THEY THOUGHT IT
POSSIBLY INCREASED I COULD HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO AN INCREASE IN
AUTO WITH US. OVERALL THEY
DIDN'T HAVE SIGNIFICAN IMPACTS
ON ON THE RATE OF CRIME. THANK
YOU. FOR YES IT INDEED. IN THE
REPORT THAT THE- PROP FORTY
SEVEN. MAY HAVE AFFECTED THOSE
STEPS THAT YOU ROOF WE REFER.
TO IT DOES NOT SHOW BUT IT DOES
NOT SHOW THAT INCREASE IN TERMS
OF THE YEAR TO YEAR SO CLEARLY
WE'RE STILL GONNA NEED DATA
WE'RE GONNA NEED DATA FOR
NINETEEN- AND I THINK IT WOULD
BE VERY HELPFUL IMPORTANT TO
GET THAT DATA BECAUSE-
INDEPENDENT OF THE INITIATIVE.
WE HAVE THE LAW THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER. AUTHORED
IN THAT IS IN EFFECT WHICH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THAT'S
REGARDING THE- ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I'D LIKE TO KNOW BUT I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE THE DATA YET IS
WHETHER THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE. IN WELL MAYBE NOT AN
INCREASE BECAUSE IT DIDN'T
EXIST BUT WHAT IS THE LEVEL OF
A REST THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
NOW THAT THAT LAWS IN EFFECT
WHAT'S THE LEVEL OF
CONVICTIONS- IS. IT AGAIN WITH
SUCH DATA MIGHT INDICATE TO US
EITHER THAT- MINIS ARE TRICKY
BECAUSE- IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
UTILIZING THE TOOL THAT WAS
PROVIDED- HAS IT BEEN
EFFECTIVE- BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY TO
EXTEND IT IT HAS TO SUNSET IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT- THE
LEGISLATURE. COULD IT CHOOSE
TO- EXTENDED- BUT IT'S ALSO AS
WAS REFERENCED BY OUR ILIO
ELEMENTS OF IT ARE BUILT INTO
THIS INITIATIVE. AND IF IT'S- I
MEAN PART OF WHAT WE'D WANT TO
KNOW IS YOU KNOW WHAT IS IT-
LEGITIMATE TO CONTINUE IT OR
NOT BUT WE NEED THE DATA BEFORE
WE CAN. IN REALLY GET THAT
NIGHT OUT YOU HAVE IT. NO I
DON'T HAVE IT WITH ME BUT- WHEN
WE WORK ON OUR BALLOT MATERIALS
WE TYPICALLY DO REQUEST
ARRESTING CONVICTION DATA FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THAT IS LIKELY A CRIME THAT WE
WILL REQUEST. A DATE ON TO
INFORM THE ANALYSIS THAT WE
PREPARE THIS SPRING GOOD I LOOK
FORWARD TO IT NOW YOU RAISED
THE POINT THAT. WHAT PROP FIFTY
SEVEN DOES AND THIS INITIATIVE
DOES ON DO A NUMBER OF. ASPECTS
OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN THE WHAT IT
DOES IS IT CHANGES SOME-
OFFENSES THAT WERE FELONIES TWO
MISDEMEANORS BUT IT PRIMARILY
IT GIVES- INCARCERATED PEOPLE
THE ABILITY TO GET CREDIT FOR
TIME SERVED. FOR CERTAIN
REHABILITATIVE BEHAVIORS BUT
WHAT I WANT TO CLEAR FIND YOU
STATED THIS BUT I WANTED TO RE
EMPHASIZE IT AND HAVE YOU
ADDRESS THIS IS THAT WHILE IT'S
CREDIT FOR TIME SERVED IT'S
REALLY JUST THE ABILITY TO GO
BEFORE THE PRO BOARD EARLIER.
IT DOES NOT MANDATE THE PAROLE
BOARD TO RELEASE SOMEONE SO
WHAT I AM INTERESTED IN AND I
JUST WANNA BE REALLY CLEAR
THERE'S A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT SOMEHOW
PROP FIFTY SEVEN GUARANTEES
PEOPLE'S RELEASED EARLIER NO IT
DOES NOT. IT PURELY ALLOWS YOU
TO GO BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
EARLIER IF YOU HAVE DONE THESE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
PROPERLY- BUT SO WHAT I'M
INTERESTED IN HAS THERE BEEN
ANY INCREASE IN DECISIONS BY
THE PAROLE BOARD REGARDING
RELEASE BECAUSE THE DATA I HAVE
SEEN IS THAT OVER THE YEARS
THERE'S BEEN NO DIFFERENCE.
IT'S ABOUT 18% 1118% LIKELIHOOD
WHETHER PROP FIFTY SEVEN PROST
PROFIT. SEVEN WE'RE GETTING.
WHEN YOU GO ABOVE THE PROBE OR
DO A DIFFERENT IN DATA. SOME OF
THE MEASURE- A CREATED A NEW
PEARL PROCESS FOR NONVIOLENT
OFFENDERS- THAT THE RELEASE
RATE IS AROUND THAT THE NUMBER
THAT YOU CITED. IT HAS CHANGED
MAYBE SLIGHTLY IN RECENT YEARS
BUT NOT SIGNIFICANTLY SO WE
COULD GO AHEAD GOOD THE ONLY
THING I WOULD ADD IS THAT-
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
CONSIDERED FOR PAROLE NOW UNDER
PROPERTY SEVEN THAT ONE TO HAVE
BEEN CONSIDERED FOR PAROLE.
ABSENT THE MEASURE AND SO WELL
THOSE FOLKS ARE GETTING
RELEASED AT THE SORT OF
HISTORIC 18% RATE THOSE FOLKS
WANT OF BEEN RELEASED WITHOUT
THE MEASURE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GO BEFORE CORRECT
CORRECT- BUT I THINK THE
IMPORTANT. POINT HERE IS. I
THINK WOULD BE WITH WORTH IT
AND USEFUL TO GET SOME MORE
DATA BECAUSE. PART OF THE
PURPOSE OF FIFTY SEVEN. WAS NOT
ONLY TO LOOK AT HOW WE SENSE
MORE RATIONALLY AND HOW WE- TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING THE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING THAT- WE INTEND NOW
THAT WE HAVE OUR DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. BUT IN FACT MY
IN AND PART OF IT ALSO WAS TO
ASSIST US IN MEETING THE COURT
ORDERED GOAL FOR POPULATION
REDUCTION. WHAT WOULD BE
INTERESTING IS TO REALLY GET
NUMBERS ON HOW MUCH IT REALLY
HAS A CHEAP THAT SO IN OTHER
WORDS THERE I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT SOME OF THE INITIATIVE
PROPONENTS FEEL THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME. A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
A HUGE WHOLESALE INCREASE IN
PEOPLE WHO WERE WHO WERE
IMPRISONED BEING RELEASED AND I
REALLY DOUBT THAT'S THE CASE
BUT- IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO
NOTE THAT. WE COULD FOLLOW UP
WITH THE YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE
DECENT DATA. IF THAT BE HELPFUL
IN. THANK YOU- LET'S SEE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE DíAS
TO ALEJO. ALRIGHT SO WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO. WHAT WE HOPED
WOULD BE THE PROPONENTS OF THE-
INITIATIVE AND AS I MENTIONED-
NINA SALERNO FROM CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED WAS GOING TO PRESENT BUT
SHE CALLED US LATE YESTERDAY
AND INDICATED THAT SHE- HAD
WITH IS NOW ILL AND WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
FROM CRIME VICTIMS UNITED. WHO
WOULD. LIKE TO ADDRESS S. I'M
ALL RIGHT WE WILL CONTINUE WITH
THE NEXT PART OF OUR AGENDA AND
IF A PROPONENT OF THE
INITIATIVE IS ABLE TO BE HERE
BEFORE WE CONCLUDE WE WILL GIVE
THEM TIME ON THAT DíAS. SO
LET'S GO NOW TO THE TOP MOMENTS
AND OF WE WILL HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND WELCOME NEW MEMBERS
WHO HAVE JOINED US SOME DATA
CENTER BRADFORD ST THE MEMBER
LACKEY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND-
KAMLAGER DEATH. THANK YOU CAN
BEGIN YOUR NEW INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. HELLO THIS. YOU'RE
RIGHT AWAY. GOOD MORNING THERE
WE GO MY NAME'S LENORE ANDERSON
ON THE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY THIS BALLOT INITIATIVE IS
UNNECESSARY IT TAKES A
CALIFORNIA'S JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
THE WRONG DIRECTION AND IT WILL
BE HARMFUL FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
FOR CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES AND FOR THE STATE
BUDGET. THE BACKERS OF THE
MEASURE WOULD LIKE VOTERS TO
FORGET ABOUT THE DECADE LONG
DECADES LONG FAILED EXPERIMENT
IN OVER INCARCERATION AND
RETURN TO THE FAILED APPROACHES
OF THE PAST WE ANTICIPATE THAT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE SMARTER
THAN THAT AND THE MEASURE WILL
BE REJECTED IN NOVEMBER FIRST
ALL DESCRIBE FOUR COMPONENTS OF
THE MEASURE THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU UNDERSTAND AND
THEN I'LL TALK ABOUT HOW IT IS
UNNECESSARY TAKES US IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION AND WILL BE
HARMFUL TO OUR STATE. THE
MEASURE REPEALS KEY ASPECTS OF
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN THAT
WAS THE BALLOT INITIATIVE THAT
CHANGED SIX LOW LEVEL CRIMES
FROM FELONIES TO MISDEMEANORS
AND ANNUALLY RE ALLOCATES
PRISON DOLLARS TO TREATMENT AND
VICTIM SERVICES SPECIFICALLY
THIS MEASURE AUTHORIZES FELONY
CONVICTIONS FOR LOW LEVEL THEFT
CRIMES BY REDUCING THE FELONY
THRESHOLD FROM NINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS TO TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOR SPECIFIED
OFFENSES CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE
ONE OF THE LOWEST PHONY
THRESHOLDS FOR THEFT CRIMES IN
THE NATION FOR EXAMPLE IN TEXAS
THE PHONY THRESHOLD IS TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THIS IS WAY OUT OF LINE WITH
WHAT VOTERS WANT SECOND IT
REPEALS KEY ASPECTS OF PROP
FIFTY SEVEN THE BALLOT MEASURE
THAT REQUIRES REHABILITATION
FOR PEOPLE IN PRISON
SPECIFICALLY IT DOUBLES THE
NUMBER OF OFFENSES THAT ARE
EXCLUDED FROM ELIGIBILITY FOR
REHABILITATION CREDITS TOWARDS
RELEASE IT ALLEGES THAT IS
ENSURING THAT A BUNCH OF CRIMES
WILL THEN BE CONSIDERED VILE.
IT'S BUT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
CHANGING THE SENTENCING OF ANY
OF THOSE CRIMES AT ALL INSTEAD
IT SIMPLY PREVENTING PEOPLE IN
PRISON FOR THERE'S CRIMES FROM
BEING INCENTIVIZED TO COMPLETE
REHABILITATION AND PREPARE FOR
RELEASE. NEXT THE MEASURE
REPEALS KEY ASPECTS OF PROPS OF
TWENTY ELEVENS PUBLIC SAFETY
REALIGNMENTS BY AUTHORIZING
PEOPLE- ON COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION WHO VIOLATE SOME
TERMS A RETURN TO PRISON
INSTEAD OF USING LOCAL
GRADUATED SANCTIONS THIS WILL
DRIVE THE PRISON POPULATION UP.
FOURTH AND REALLY IMPORTANTLY.
THIS IS A MEASURE THAT WILL
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF STATE
MONEY THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
CRIME PREVENTION AND SMARTER
APPROACHES TO LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY. PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN
HAS ALREADY SAVED AN ESTIMATED
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
MONEY FOR VICTIMS SERVICES
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT AND
YOUTH PROGRAMS. THAT WILL
REDUCE IF THE POPULATION GOES
UP. BACKERS OF THIS MEASURE ARE
FOCUSED ON FEAR MONGERING TO
PAINT A GRIM PICTURE THAT
JUSTICE REFORM IS CONTRIBUTING
TO VIOLENT CRIME. THAT IS
FALSE. CRIME CALIFORNIA REMAINS
AT HISTORIC LOWS SHIFTS IN
CRIME RATES THAT ARE OBSERVABLE
IN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO NOT
HOLD CONSISTENTLY STATEWIDE THE
VERY MARKEDLY FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY. STATE POLICY IS NOT THE
PROBLEM THIS MEASURE IS
UNNECESSARY. IT'S UNNECESSARY
TO IMPROVE RESPONSES TO LOW
LEVEL CRIMES BECAUSE FIRST THE
VAST MAJORITY OF LOW LEVEL
CRIMES ARE NOT REPORTED TO
POLICE THIS HAS BEEN THE CASE
SINCE LONG BEFORE THE JUSTICE
REFORM ERA EMERGED. PROPERTY
CRIME CLEARANCE RATES ARE
TYPICALLY LESS THAN 20% SO A
FOCUS ON SENTENCING PEOPLE
CONVICTED IS IT HAS A VERY
LIMITED IMPACT CRIME PREVENTION
HAS A MUCH BROADER REACH SECOND
IT'S UNNECESSARY BECAUSE THE
TOOLS ALREADY EXIST. TO HOLD
PEOPLE UP COULD BE CONVICTED OF
LOW LEVEL CRIMES ACCOUNTABLE
WHETHER THOSE TOOLS ARE USED
LOCALLY OR NOT UNDER CALIFORNIA
LAW LAW ENFORCEMENT IN A- AND
DETAIN ME. AND COURTS CAN
ENGAGE IN A MIX OF SANCTIONS
INCLUDING TREATMENT COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION AND UP TO A YEAR IN
JAILTIME AT AS WELL AS
INCENTIVES TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. THIRD IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A. B. C. TEN SIXTY
SIZE TEN- SIXTY FIVE
LEGISLATION ALSO STRENGTHENED
ORGANIZE RETAIL THEFT LAW TO
IMPROVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY TO ARREST AND DETAIN
PEOPLE- IN GAUGING IN REPEAT
AFTER CRIMES. IT'S ALSO ON
NECESSARY TO IMPROVE RESPONSES
TO VIOLENT CRIME BECAUSE
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT CRIME STILL
KERRY LONG SENTENCES REGARDLESS
OF PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN ALL
FELONIES BY DEFINITION ARE
EITHER SERIOUS OR VIOLENT
CRIMES AND CAN CARRY LENGTHY
PRISON TERMS. THE PROBLEM IS
NOT WHETHER OR NOT PROSECUTORS
AND COURTS CAN ARE.
SUFFICIENTLY LOCK PEOPLE UP FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME MANY
THOUSANDS ARE INCARCERATED IN
THIS STATE EVERY YEAR THE
PROBLEM IS WHAT HAPPENS BEFORE
PEOPLE ARE RELEASED AND THAT'S
THE PROBLEM THE PROPERTY SEVEN
SOUGHT TO RESOLVE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS. ARE
GETTING OUT THE QUESTION WE
NEED TO ASK IS DO WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE RELEASED PREPARED
FOR RE ENTRY OR NOT BY REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR REHABILITATION
CREDITS WERE ACTUALLY HARMING
PUBLIC SAFETY. NOT HELPING IT
THERE'S NO RESEARCH THAT STATES
THAT LONG SENTENCES AND
WAREHOUSE STYLE INCARCERATION
WORK IN FACT RESEARCH SAYS
SHORTER SENTENCES WITH MORE
INFORMATION. WITH MORE EMPHASIS
ON PREPARATION FOR RELEASE IS
IT WHAT REDUCES REPEAT
OFFENDING. WORSE THAN BEING ON.
THIS MEASURE IT WILL MOVE
CALIFORNIA IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION QUICKLY A COUPLE OF
THE KEY REASONS IT'LL MOVE THE
STATE IN THE WRONG DIRECTION
AND LEAD TO MORE INCARCERATION
IN MORE PRISON COSTS. ROUGH
ESTIMATES THAT AS MANY AS TEN
THOUSAND MORE PEOPLE WILL BE
INCARCERATED IN THE STATE
ANNUALLY SECOND IT WILL LEAD TO
MORE LITIGATION THIS STATE IS
NOW JUST COMING OUT OF UNDER
THE THUMB FROM FEDERAL LAWSUITS
AND RETURNING TO NON COMPLIANCE
WOULD BE HARMFUL. THIRD IT'LL
LEAD TO FEWER OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STABILITY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING WITH PAST FELONY
CONVICTIONS FELONY CONVICTIONS
COME WITH A LIFETIME OF
CONSEQUENCES FROM PROHIBITIONS
TO EMPLOYMENT TO HOUSING AND
MORE. CREATING MORE FELONY
CONVICTIONS FOR LOW LEVEL CRIME
IS BAD FOR THE ECONOMY AND WILL
DESTABILIZE COMMUNITIES FURTHER.
FOURTH THIS WILL ALSO LEAD TO
FEWER DOLLARS TO HELP VICTIMS
OF CRIME. IN JUST THE SHORT
TIME SINCE PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN PASSED CALIFORNIA HAS
GONE FROM HAVING ONLY ONE
TRAUMA RECOVERY CENTER TO NOW
HAVING FOURTEEN TRAUMA RECOVERY
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE. THESE
ARE MODEL PROGRAMS THE
SPECIFICALLY SIEGE SEARCH OUT
AND FIND. UNDERSERVED VICTIMS
OF CRIME VICTIMS OF CRIME OF
SUCH AS SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
OTHER CRIMES IN WHICH THE
TRADITIONAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM HAS BEEN LIMITED IN ITS
ABILITY TO HELP THESE VICTIMS.
WE NEED MORE TRUMP RECOVERY
CENTERS NOT LESS. TO BE SURE WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO ENSURE
SAFETY AND DIGNITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND TO GROW
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WORKS
EFFECTIVELY FOR EVERYONE. TO
MOVE CALIFORNIA FORWARD WE
ABSOLUTELY MUST BUILD MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE
ENTERING THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
SCALE UP CISIS RESPONSE BUILD
MORE TROUBLE FROM RECOVERY
CENTERS AND MANY MORE REFORMS.
BUT GOING BACKWARDS IS A
DISASTROUS PROPOSAL OUR STATE
IS JUST NOW RECOVERING FROM
RACIALIZED FEAR MONGERING
APPROACHES TO PUBLIC POLICY.
OUR COMMUNITIES DESERVE REAL
HELP NOT A FEAR MONGERING SCAM
THAT PRETENDS TO CARE ABOUT
VICTIMS OF CRIME AND WE URGE
THAT THIS MEASURE BE REJECTED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. KAMLAGER DOVE IN
QUESTION MR LACKEY. I. THE
THING THE THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION- I WHAT WASN'T
TOUCHED ON AND I SHOULD VAST
ILIO ALSO BUT PART OF OUR- HI
PRISON POPULATION IS WE STILL
HAVE HIGH RECIDIVISM RATES. AND
MEANING WE AND THERE'S LOTS ONE
COULD ARGUE. WELL IT IT'S GOOD
TO SEE DATA AROUND RECIDIVISM
BECAUSE SOME OF OUR RECIDIVISM
IS DUE TO ANOTHER CRIME THAT
WAS COMMITTED BUT SOME IS STILL
DUE TO VIOLATIONS AND NOT
NECESSARILY THAT IN OTHER CRIME
WAS COMMITTED. FIVE AND I THINK
YOU TOUCHED ON THE ISSUE OF IF
WE CREATE. A BROADER CATEGORY
OF PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO GET
FELONIES THAT WE THEN HAVE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE OF ONE ONE STATE
ASSUMING THAT THEY ARE ARRESTED
AND CONVICTED AND SERVED TIME
FOR THEIR PHONY ONCE THEY
RETURN HOME THEY HAVE THIS VERY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCE IN FACT
FOR EVER. OF EITHER GETTING
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT OR SECURING
HOUSING OR VARIETY OF THINGS TO
DO TO THAT FELONY CONVICTION SO
COULD YOU SPEAK TO FOR A MOMENT
AROUND THE CONNECTION TO
RECIDIVISM WHICH IS ALSO
OBVIOUSLY PART OF WHAT WE NEED
TO PAY ATTENTION TO. IF WE ARE
BOTH TRYING TO REDUCE THE
POPULATION IN OUR PRISONS AND
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER. THE
ABSOLUTELY IF SO WHAT
CALIFORNIA VOTERS- WANT MORE
THAN ANYTHING FROM THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS A SYSTEM THAT HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE STOPS CYCLES
OF CRIME AND GIVES PEOPLE A
PATHWAY TO MEETING FOR
REHABILITATION AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT MEANINGFUL REHABILITATION
WE TALK ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY POST
CONVICTION AFTER YOUR TIME IS
DONE WHAT WE SEE IN CALIFORNIA
IT LIKE MANY STATES IS IT'S
NEAR IMPOSSIBLE TO GET BACK ON
YOUR FEET. EFFECTIVELY AND
QUICKLY WHEN YOU'RE LIVING WITH
A PAST FELONY CONVICTION IT
WASN'T JUST THE INCARCERATION
RATES THAT SKYROCKETED IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES IT WAS
ALSO THE NUMBER OF FELONIES IN
THE PENAL CODES AND THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE CONVICTED OF FELONY
OFFENSES ONE IN EIGHT
CALIFORNIANS HAS A FELONY
CONVICTION ON THEIR PAST RECORD
THE QUESTION WE NEED TO ASK
OURSELVES IS WHAT DOES MEANING
FOR REHABILITATION REALLY MEAN
PEOPLE HAVE COMPLETED TERMS OF
THE SENTENCE THE OPPORTUNITY
SHOULD BE TO GET TO GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT ACCESS TO A STABLE
HOUSING ACCESS TO JOBS THESE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
MAKE OUR COMMUNITY SAFE WHEN WE
PREVENT THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE. ARE TO GAIN ACCESS TO
MEANINGFUL REHABILITATION WORK
HARMING PUBLIC SAFETY AND
REDUCING THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THE PERSON CAN STAY OUT OF THE
CYCLE OF CRIME. MS COME A GOOD
OVEN IN A. THANK YOU I KNOW
THAT THE PROPONENTS OF THIS
INITIATIVE ARE NOT HERE- AND I
DO HAVE TO SAY THAT TIME I'M
SORRY FOR THAT BECAUSE WHEN
YOU'RE NOT HERE YOU CREATE A
VACUUM FOR ARGUING YOUR POINT
ALTHOUGH I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY ARE NOT. AND I ALSO WANT
TO STATE THAT EVERYONE IN THIS-
ON THESE COMMITTEES IS
COMMITTED TO PUBLIC SAFETY BUT
IT'S FIGURING OUT HOW TO INSERT
EQUITY. AND JUSTICE- INTO THAT
I WOULD HOPING THAT YOU COULD
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SORT
OF. POST RELEASE SUPERVISION.
AND SORT OF WHERE WE FALL SHORT
WHERE THIS INITIATIVE MACE FALL
SHORT- AND HAT'S NOT BEING
ADDRESSED THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE AS I LOOK
THROUGH SOME OF THE LANGUAGE IN
THIS IT APPEARS TO BE RATHER
DRACONIAN TO ME. BUT IT'S ALSO.
SORT OF LIKE HOW YOU WOULD
TREAT A DOG IN A SHELTER- AND
NOT REALLY ADDRESSING YOU KNOW
TRIGGERS- THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION HOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR OTHER- FOLKS
INTERACT WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED INSTEAD
OF LOOKING AT YOU KNOW TATTOOS
ARE. ALL OF THESE OTHER THINGS
RACE WHERE THEY COME FROM
pPROGRAMS THAT THEY PARTICIPATED
IN WHILE THEY WERE INCARCERATED
WHERE THEY HAVE EXCELLED I MEAN
THAT'S PART OF THE CONVERSATION
AROUND RECIDIVISM RATE AND
LOWERING THOSE NUMBERS.
FIGURING OUT HOW YOU WE CAN
BEGIN TO INTERACT TO RE
INTERACT WITH FOLKS IN A WAY
THAT IS SUCCESSFUL AND
COMPASSIONATE HOLDS FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE BUT DOESN'T TREAT
THEM LIKE ANIMALS ON THE
STREET. SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT'S NOT IN HERE AND MAYBE
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT ON A BROADER
LEVEL AS IT RELATES TO THAT. AT
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. WHY ARE
ORGANIZATION CONDUCTED A-
PUBLIC OPINION RESEARCH STUDY
AND IN TWENTY. EIGHTEEN WHERE
WE- INTERVIEWED CALIFORNIANS
LIVING WITH PAST CONVICTIONS TO
TRY TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF.
THE EXPERIENCE BOTH LIVING WITH
THE PAST CONVICTION BUT ALSO-
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
INVOLVEMENT IN THEIR IN CRIME
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND ONE IN TWO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED. ANSWERED THAT
EITHER A SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR
MENTAL HEALTH OF IT CHALLENGES
LEAD TO INVOLVEMENT IN CRIME
RIGHT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
DRIVERS OF CRIME WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT MAKING COMMUNITY SAFER.
THIS ISN'T IT'S NOT A MYSTERY
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE IN THE
PATHWAY TOWARDS- INVOLVEMENT IN
CRIME. THE REAL MYSTERY IS WHY
ARE WE ADDRESSING THOSE DRIVERS
OF CRIME ON THE FRONT END- WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT WHO'S IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO. ARE
EXPERIENCING STRUGGLES WITH
DRUG ABUSE OR ALCOHOL ABUSE
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES ARE
NOT ABLE TO QUICKLY AND READILY
ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT.
THAT SHOULD BE A PUBLIC SAFETY
PRIORITY THAT SHOULD BE WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW TO IMPROVE
COMMUNITY SAFETY ONE WOULD
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE AT THE
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST. OF
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING TO HELP
COMMUNITIES AND HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION
OR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. THE
FAILURE TO DO SO. AP IS PART OF
WHAT IS SO. DISINGENUOUS ABOUT
BOTH THIS MEASURE AND THE AND
THE BROADER BOB MASS
INCARCERATION ERA THAT WE'RE
RECOVERING FROM. INSTEAD OF
ADDRESSING THE CYCLE OF CRIME
OR OBVIOUS STOPPING IT. IN MANY
WAYS THE EXPLOSION OF THE
PRISON SYSTEM AND THE TOUGH
PUNISHMENT APPROACH TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. IT REALLY ACTUALLY HAS
DONE MORE TO SUBSIDIZE. CYCLES
OF CRIME THAN IT HAS TO
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THEM OR STOP
THEM. WE KNOW HOW TO MAKE
COMMUNITY SAFE WE'VE GOT. TO
TALK ABOUT TRAUMA AND TRAUMA
RECOVERY FOR CAN. WE'VE GOT TO
TALK ABOUT MENTAL TREATMENT SUB
ABUSE TREATMENT AND GIVING
PEOPLE REAL STABILITY DIGNITY
AND STABILITY AFTER THEIR TIME
IS DONE THAT'S WHAT WOULD
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
THAT'S WHAT'S MISSING FROM THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU MISTER
LACKEY. YEAH THANK YOU FIRST OF
ALL I'D I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THAT- THE MAJORITY THE
PEOPLE ON THIS DIRE CENTER THAT
ARE IN HERE TODAY ARE NOT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE BUT I
DO THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO
INSINUATED SUPPORTERS WHO ARE
ABLE TO MAKE IT THIS MORNING
WERE SOMEWHERE INTENTIONALLY
ABSENT AND I DON'T TAKE THAT
LIGHTLY AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
FAIR. SECONDLY YOU DID MENTION
THAT TO ONE OUT OF A
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A FELONY ON
THE RECORD IS THAT THE RIGHT
ONE IN A CALIFORNIANS HAS A
CONVICTION. OKAY WE'RE THAT
STOCK COME FROM SHOCKING
RESEARCH THAT. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DATA FROM THE STATE.
OKAY NOT NOT THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE STATE
NOW OKAY THERE. SHE HIGHER
NATIONALLY OKAY I'D LIKE TO
JUST FOLLOW THAT UP WITH THANK
YOU. YES SENATE JACKSON THANK
YOU- IN AND I'M DISAPPOINTED TO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROPONENTS AND I'M NOT GOING TO
TRY TO SPECULATE AS TO WHY NOT
BUT THIS IS THEIR INITIATIVE
AND- IT WOULD HAVE BEEN HELPFUL
TO HEAR FROM THEM BUT- THAT
BEING SAID- I APPRECIATE YOUR-
YOUR PASSION ON THIS ISSUE AND-
SOME OF THE STATISTICS WHICH
ARE KIND OF STUNNING- BUT- I'M
WONDERING. IF PART OF THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF REHABILITATION
AND SO WE CAN REDUCE THE
RECIDIVISM RATE REALLY DEALS
WITH THE KIND OF PROGRAMS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PEOPLE HAVE
WHILE INCARCERATED. AND IT'S
BEEN A FRUSTRATION TO ME- TO
FIND THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS HAS A VIRTUALLY
OPAQUE- APPROACH TO- SHARING
WITH US AS LEGISLATORS- IS TO
SAY NOTHING OF THE PUBLIC JUST
EXACTLY WHAT KIND OF PROGRAMS
AND OPPORTUNITIES EXIST IN
PRISON FOR PEOPLE- SO THAT THEY
CAN LEARN A TRADE SO THEY CAN
DEAL WITH THEIR ANGER
MANAGEMENT OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND WHAT HAVE YOU- SUPPOSEDLY
WE'RE PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO
THAT. BUT I'M WONDERING IF YOU
CAN COMMENT IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY HOLD THIS DEPARTMENT
ACCOUNTABLE IT TAKES WHAT ABOUT
10212% OF OUR STATE. BUDGET
GOES TO CORRECTIONS AND IF
WE'RE NOT SEEING A REAL
IMPROVEMENT IN A REDUCTION IN
OUR RECIDIVISM RATE WHEN WE
KNOW. WHAT SOME OF THESE THINGS
ARE THAT WILL REDUCE RECIDIVISM
I'M WONDERING IF MY
CHARACTERIZATION IS SEEN IN
YOUR OPINION- INACCURATE OR
WHAT YOU WOULD RECOMMEND WE DO
TO TRY TO LIFT THE VEIL OF
SECRECY THAT EXISTS IN HALF FOR
DECADES IN THIS AGENCY IN IN
THIS DEPARTMENT. WE SAW A
COUPLE COUPLE OF THOUGHTS
RESPONSE YOUR QUESTION THE
FIRST IS THAT WHAT IS
PROMISING. A ABOUT THE STATE OF
CORRECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA IS
THAT AS THE- PRISON CROWDING
PROBLEM HAS BEEN ADDRESSED AND
AS WE'VE SEEN A FEW WERE OF
PEOPLE IN PRISON IT'S ACTUALLY
INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE EMPHASIS ON
REHABILITATION. SO THAT TODAY
THERE'S PROBABLY MORE
REHABILITATION INSIDE A
CALIFORNIA'S CORRECTION SYSTEM
THEN THERE HAS BEEN EVER. AND
THAT'S A VERY GOOD POSITIVE
DIRECTION THAT WE SHOULD BE
APPLAUDING AND THANKING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM FOR
MAKING POSSIBLE RIGHT BECAUSE-
WE HAVE HAD A SEVERE PRISON
CROWDING CRISIS FOR SO MANY
DECADES THAT EVEN. THE BEST OF
INTENTIONS ON THE PART OF A
PEOPLE RUNNING THE SYSTEM WOULD
BE WHERE WOULD YOU PUT THE
REHABILITATION IF PEOPLE- ARE
IAN- DOUBLE TRIPLE BOX AND SO
CROWDED IN THE SYSTEM SO THE
FIRST STEP TO CHANGING THE
CULTURE OF CORRECTIONS. IS
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
UNNECESSARILY IN IT ONCE WE
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
UNNECESSARILY IN IT WE CAN
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF
CORRECTIONS BY CHANGE HOW WE
TRAIN OUR PEOPLE IN THE
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM. INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT GOES
TOWARDS TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THE SYSTEM AND THEN
CHANGING THE STANDARDS BY WHICH
WERE MEASURING OUR SUCCESS UPON
RELEASE REHABILITATION HAS GOT
TO BE FRONT AND CENTER. IN OUR
APPROACH TO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO DO IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
DECADES WITH OUR A CORRECTION
SYSTEM. YES IN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I. TOO
I'M SORRY THAT THERE ISN'T A
PROPONENT- SO I'M NOT GONNA ASK
QUESTIONS TO MAKE OBSERVATIONS
IF I COULD MISTER CHAIR JUST AS
A AS A FORMERCOUNTY SUPERVISOR
I WAS SENT. I WAS CHAIRMAN IN
TWENTY TWELVE AND IN AB ONE ON
NINE WAS PASSED IN THE TWENTY
ELEVEN SO I. HAD THE JOYS OF
DEALING WITH. THE
REVERBERATIONS OF THE EARLY
RELEASE. THEN FOLLOWED BY FORTY
SEVEN AND FIFTY SEVEN SO. BUT
I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND THE
BALLOT MEASURE BUT I I'M HERE
TO SAY THAT ANECDOTALLY I HAVE
PLENTY OF CONSTITUENTS THAT
HAVE COME TO ME AND- HAVE
OBSERVED. SOME CHANGES IN THE
COMMUNITY AND SO I DON'T KNOW
IF THE EARLY RELEASE OF
PRISONERS IS HIT IT THERE'S A
CORRELATION TO THE INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT I'M CERTAINLY.
A RECIPIENT OF A OF A LOT OF
CONCERNS SO THERE FOR SOMEONE
HAS FUNDED THE ABILITY TO
RAISE. ENOUGH SIGNATURES AND I
DON'T KNOW WHO THAT IS- SO I
CAN'T ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS-
I WOULD MAYBE ASSUME IT COULD
BE RETAILERS. WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR
STORES BECAUSE- IF THEY HAVE A
SHOPLIFTING ISSUE THEN THEN
THOSE COSTS ARE. PASSED ALONG
TO- TO CONSUMERS AND CONSUMERS
ARE CONSTITUENTS. AND SO WE
HAVE A REACTION SO I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THAT- MISS ANDERSON
IS SAID IN. AN A YOU CERTAINLY
KNOW WHERE I'M AT WITH TRYING
TO DEAL WITH- MENTAL SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL AND ALL THE REST
AS IT RELATES TO. INDIVIDUALS
IN CRIME AND LOWERS LINE AND SO
I'M I'M IN THAT SPACE. BUT
SOMEHOW THERE'S A REACTION. AND
HOW DO WE FIND THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE IF THIS IS NOT IT BEEN
WHAT CAN WE DO WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO. TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
FEELING SAFE ABOUT GOING TO THE
GROCERY STORE OR WHEREVER THEY
GO DURING THEIR DAILY. LIFE AND
CHORES SO THAT WOULD BE MY-
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS.
DISCUSSION AND AGAIN I'M I'M
SORRY THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROPONENTS HER YEAH. THANK YOU
AND- IN. TAKE YOUR AGENT OKAY.
LOOK I I'M PROBABLY GONNA
REVISIT- ORGANIZED RETAIL DEATH
LOG IN BECAUSE ALSO BELIEVE. AT
THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEGISLATIVELY
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS THAT
COULD HELP WITH SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON OUT
THERE AND- I'M JUST GONNA
REGION ARTICLE. FROM SAN
FRANCISCO GATE- THAT ARE IN USE
A NEWSPAPER ARTICLE- WEDNESDAY
TWENTY NINE TWENTY TWENTY.
THREE OAKLAND SISTERS HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH RUNNING A RETAIL
THEFT RING. THAT INVOLVES
SELLING MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
MERCHANDISE. THE THREE SISTERS
WERE CHARGED ON JANUARY
FOURTEENTH MY BIRTHDAY
INSTANTLY. WITH FELONY COUNTS
OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THAT
AFFECTIONATELY CALLED J. SORT.
IN CONCERT WITH TO MORE PEOPLE
DIRECTING ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT RECEIVING STOLEN PROPERTY
HAYWARD POLICE SAID THAT THEY
STEPPED UP THEIR PRESENCE AT
THE MALL. THAT THE NUMBER OF
GRAB AND RUN DEATHS DECREASED
AND ONE STORE EVEN SAID IT
HASN'T HAD A GRAB AND RUN SINCE
THE INCREASED AND POLICE
PRESENCE. THE SISTERS EVEN SOLD
ITEMS IN THE BACK AND SIDE
YARDS AT THEIR OAKLAND HOMES
WHICH WERE CONVERTED INTO STORE
AREAS COMPLETE WITH THE WEATHER
PROTECTION. CLOTHING RACKS
SHELVING LIGHTING HEATING GLASS
DISPLAY CASES SHOPPING BAGS AND
PAY LEDGERS. AMONG THE STORES
IN DIFFERENT CITIES THAT WERE
TARGETED WERE MACY'S TARGET JC
PENNEY HOME DEPOT VICTORIA'S
SECRET ON ALL ALL TRIBUTE. AT
AMERICAN EAGLE. THE POINT I'M
MAKING IS LEGISLATIVELY WE DD
SOMETHING TO TRY TO COMBAT THIS
AND WE CAN DO THAT ESPECIALLY
WITH INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
TAKING THIS TO THAT LEVEL OF
CRIMINALITY THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE BOTH SIDES OF THE
HOUSE. GOVERNOR SIGN CREATE A
LAW. TO HANDLE SOME OF THAT
ESPECIALLY THE MOST EGREGIOUS
ONCE. WHAT I HEAR YOU WHEN I
HEAR PEOPLE SAYING ON THE OTHER
SIDE AND I WILL LET YOU KNOW
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO HELPED ME
WRITE THIS LONG ONE WITH THE
RETAILERS AND THE CHAMBER. THEY
CAME IN TO HELP ME WRITE
ORGANIZED RETAIL DEATH NOT
EVERYONE IN HIS AUDIENCE RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE LOOKING AT ME FUNNY
WOOD WHAT'S WHAT'S PROBABLY ON
BOARD WITH IT. BUT WE NEEDED TO
DO SOMETHING- TO DEAL WITH AND
TAKE US WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE
ACTUALLY TOOK THAT THAT STEP
AND SO I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
OFFER. THAT OUT THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT YOU CAN WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. TO COME
UP WITH- WAYS IF THERE'S SOME
LOOPHOLES OR TO THINGS THAT
FELL UPON TO CRACKS. WE'RE HERE
TO- MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS TO
WE DIDN'T NEED TO. PROBABLY GO
TO THIS KIND OF EFFORT AND SO I
IN A NIGHT. I WILL OFFER MY- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SENATE WE'RE
STILL HERE- TO MAKE SURE THAT
ONE WE PROTECT PEOPLE WHO NEED
REHABILITATION. I DID NOT IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE IN SEIZE DC ARE ALL
WORKING. AND THE ONES THAT
AREN'T WORKING WE EITHER GET
GET THE MORE MORE FUNDING- WE
GET A BETTER HELP OR TO JUST
NOT WORKING AT ALL WE
DISCONTINUE THEM AT A MOVE THAT
MONEY. TO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING AND MAKING
SURE THAT PEOPLE DON'T
RECIDIVISTS SPECIALLY FOR
SPENDING EIGHTY. EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO
INCARCERATE SOMEONE I RATHER
HAVE SOMEONE OUT WORKING. NOT
STEALING- CONTRIBUTED COMMUNITY
RAISING A FAMILY PAYING TAXES.
IN A LOT OF TAXES AND BECOME A-
OF. A MEMBER OF THE OF
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY AND SO WITH
THAT I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING IS A CONCERN THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING. WITH THE
CRIMINALITY OF IT SPACE AT THE
HIGHER LEVELS BUT WE ALSO NEED
TO WE NEED TO REALLY STEP UP
OUR REHABILITATION PROCESS
BECAUSE- AND I'M NOT THROWING
AB ONE ON ONE OH NINE PEOPLE
INTO THE BRIDGE BUT- UNDER
WHAT. BUT MOST OF US HERE WE
DIDN'T WE ARE PART OF THAT. AND
I THINK WE NEED IT PROBABLY A
LITTLE MORE- SAME WITH FIFTY
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN WE JUST NEED
TO IMPLEMENTED BETTER. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHY SOME THE ANGST
THAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM.
INDIVIDUALS ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THIS. AND SO I'M I'M HOPING
THAT. AS WE MOVE FORWARD EVEN
THIS YEAR THAT PEOPLE COME TO.
TO OUR OFFICES WITH WAYS WE CAN
BOTH ADDRESS BOTH OF THESE
PROBLEMS. THE ONLY THING I
WANTED TO RAISE WHICH YOU DID
NOT ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER IS THAT. THE ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT LAW WAS. WORKED ON
AND THEN PASSED. IN EFFECT
CONCURRENTLY WITH THE SIGNATURE
COLLECTION OF THIS INITIATIVE
AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROPONENTS HERE TO KNOW WHETHER.
IF IT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING BUT
AGAIN THIS IS NOW SPECULATION
SINCE THEY'RE OUT HERE THAT
SOME WHO WERE INVOLVED IN BE.
SIGNATURE GATHERING IN THE RICH
INITIAL PART OF THE INITIATIVE.
WE WERE HAVE SOME AT ARE LESS
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT AS AS
ENTHUSIASTIC OR- THEY MAY NOT
HAVE- COMPLETELY STEP BACK TO
OPPOSE THE INITIATIVE BUT THERE
THE WORST FEELING QUITE- COULD
ABOUT THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT LOT THAT WAS PUT INTO
EFFECT BUT AGAIN WE WON'T
REALLY KNOW THAT UNLESS THEY'RE
HERE TO SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
BUT IT I THINK IT'S JUST
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
TIMING. THAT THE LAW THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER WAS
DEVELOPED CONCURRENTLY TO THE
POINT THAT THEY WERE GATHERING
SIGNATURES SO. COME OF I HAVE-
ANOTHER QUESTION SO. BROWN
VERSUS PLOTTED OUT WITH PRISON
OVERCROWDING IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THIS INITIATIVE PUT. US
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH BOTTOM
IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO DO SO
BY INCREASING THE PRISON
POPULATION AGAIN YES. IN TWO
WEEKS. YES THANK YOU A TO COURT
BRITAIN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING. AND THEN.
GO OUR NEXT AND THE LAST
PRESENTATION WILL BE REGARDING
OTHER POLICY CONSIDERATIONS
THAT MAY- THAT MAY BE WORTH
CONSIDERING IN RELATIONSHIP TO
ANALYZING THIS INITIATIVE AND
FOR THAT WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA BRIAN RECORD DID I
PRONOUNCE THAT. CHART RETURN
RICH CHART OKAY- THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHARES MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND- MY NAME IS
BRIAN RICHARDS- I SERVICE THE
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER FOR THE
COUNTY OF ELDORADO APPEAR TO
THE EAST AND I A ALSO SERVE FAN
IN HERE TODAY IN MY CAPACITY AS
PRESIDENT OF THE G. PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA- THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. WE
STRONGLY SHARED SENTIMENT
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA MUST PROMOTE
POLICIES AND PRACTICES THAT
ENHANCE THE SAFETY OF ALL ITS
CITIZENS INCLUDING VICTIMS OF
CRIME AND MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERS OURSELVES PROBATION
SHE'S REMAIN IN DOGGED PURSUIT
OF WHAT WORKS BEST PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. SPECIFICALLY WE
BELIEVE CRIME PREVENTION AND
AVOIDANCE IS THE BEST FORM OF
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND WHEN WE
FOLLOW RESEARCH EVIDENCE AND
DATA TO GUIDE SYSTEMS AND
POLICY CHANGE WE MOVE FURTHER
TOWARD THAT GOAL. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE TO USE
STATE AND RESEARCH TO EVALUATE
WHERE CHANGE IS NEEDED AND WHAT
THOSE CHANGES SHOULD BE. WE
MUST TO DO THIS WITH THE GOAL
OF CONTINUAL IMPROVEMENT IN
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE SHOULD
NEVER REST IN THAT PURSUIT.
RESEARCH SUPPORTS THAT
REDUCTIONS IN CRIME ARE BEST
ACHIEVED BY INTERRUPTING THE
CRIMINAL CYCLE AND CHANGING A
PERSONS LONG TERM BEHAVIOR. BY
ADDRESSING THEIR THOUGHT
PROCESSES. THIS IS COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. I OFTEN TELL
STORY- ONE TRYING TO EXPLAIN
WHAT PROBATION DOES TO THE
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THAT. WELL
IT'S THREE O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING IF THERE'S SOMEBODY
TRYING TO KICK IN MY FRONT DOOR
I AM GOING TO CALL NINE ONE ONE
AND I WANT TO SHARE STEP IF
YOU'RE A POLICE OFFICER THERE.
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. BUT
WHAT I REALLY WOULD PREFER. IS
THAT SOMETIME BEFORE THAT THREE
AM PHONE CALL. THERE WERE A
PROBATION OFFICER WORKING WITH
THAT INDIVIDUAL IN SUCH A WAY
THAT PREVENTED HIM FROM EVER
BEING THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND TO ME THAT'S THE WORK OF
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
INTERRUPTING THE CRIMINAL CYCLE
REQUIRES A CAREFUL BALANCE OF
NECESSARY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
WELL THOUGHT OUT INTERVENTIONS
THAT INCLUDE PROPER PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES TO ADDRESS RICH TO
RE OFFEND AS WELL AS CRIMINAL
GENIC. AND NON CRIMINAL GENIC
NEEDS. WE'LL SEE BALK DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION ON
INITIATIVE EIGHTEEN FORTY THERE
ARE PROVISIONS WITHIN IT THAT
WOULD GREATLY IMPACT OUR WORK
WITH CLIENTS. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
OUR PROVISIONS IN THIS
INITIATIVE THAT ARE WELL
REASONED AND WORTHY OF
DISCUSSION. WE'RE HERE TO OFFER
OUR INSIDE IN THESE PROVISIONS
AND OTHERS IS THE COMMITTEE
CARRIES OUT A CHARGE. FIRST THE
INITIATIVE LOOKS TO MODIFY
POLICIES ESTABLISHED WITH THE
PASSAGE OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN LET ME
STATE UP FRONT. OUR
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTED PROP
FIFTY SEVEN. BASED ON A
COLLECTIVE NATION WIDE
EXPERIENCE WE KNOW THAT WHEN
YOU IMPLEMENT PRACTICE IN
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROVEN TO
WORK IN CHANGING CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR YOU DECREASE THE RISK
OF RECIDIVISM. AND WHEN YOU
DECREASE THE RISK OF RECIDIVISM
YOU DECREASE CRIME. AND YOU
CREATE SAFER COMMUNITIES. AREAS
ASPECTS PROP FIFTY SEVEN THE
PROMOTED THESE PRACTICES MOVE
THE NEEDLE TOWARD IMPROVED
OUTCOMES. ADDITIONALLY PROP
FIFTY SEVEN WAS A THOUGHTFULLY
CONSIDER RESPONSE TO CONTINUED
PRESSURE FROM THE FEDERAL
COURTS WHO DEMANDED THE
CALIFORNIA DO SOMETHING TO EASE
THE OVERCROWDING IN OUR PRISONS
OR RISK HAVING FEDERAL
OFFICIALS- DO THAT FOR US.
RELEASING PERSONS BASED ON SOME
ARBITRARY ELEMENTS SUCH AS
THEIR TIME IN RESIDENTS OR
CRIME COMMITTED RATHER THAN
THEIR PREPAREDNESS FOR RELEASE
WOULD HAVE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
AS PREPARED ANALYSIS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING CORRECTLY
POINTS OUT WE MUST REMAIN
CONCERNED THE CHANGES IN OUR
SYSTEM BE VIEWED IN THE CONTEXT
OF ANY POTENTIAL PRESSURES ON
OUR PRISON CAPACITY. WHICH
COULD LEAD TO FUTURE ARBITRARY
RELEASES. THE CHIEFS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY TAKEN A POSITION
THAT ARBITRARY RELEASES WOULD
RESULT NEGATIVELY ON PUBLIC
SAFETY. MAKING THE MOST WELL
REASONED INSUPPORTABLE CHANGES
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY IS OF
PARAMOUNT GUIDE FOR OUR
PREVIOUS POSITIONS AND WILL BE
THE SAME LENS THROUGH WHICH WE
ANALYZE AND PINE AND ALL
PROPOSED POLICY CHANGES.
INCLUDING THE ONES HERE TODAY.
NEXT WE WOULD POINT TO A
SPECIFIC PROPOSED CHANGE IN THE
INITIATIVE THAT WOULD REQUIRE A
PETITION FOR REVOCATION FIRED
BY THE COURT UPON ANY THREE
VIOLATIONS OF PROBATION. OVER
THE LAST DECADE SEVERAL
SIGNIFICANT AND EFFECTIVE
POLICY REFORMS HAVE OCCURRED IN
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY THE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN PUBLIC SAFETY
REALIGNMENT. AND THE ENACTMENT
OF SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT. THESE
EFFORTS WERE STRUCTURED ON THE
PHILOSOPHY OF PROVIDING LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY ENTITIES THE
ABILITY TO ADDRESS OFFENDER
BEHAVIOR IN A MANNER BEST FIT
TO LOCAL CONDITIONS. AND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE INDIVIDUAL
VERSUS TO PRESCRIBE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH. EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH ON EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES SAYS THE BETTER
OUTCOMES ARE ACHIEVED BY USING
INTERMEDIATE AND GRADUATED
SANCTIONS THAT ARE COMMENSURATE
WITH THE VIOLATIONS AND
CONSIDERED IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE CLIENT. OVER REACTION JUST
AS UNDER REACTION BY THE SYSTEM
CAN AND DOES HAVE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO THE HUMAN
CHANGE PROCESS ELAINE
REHABILITATION RISKING FURTHER
HARM TO THE COMMUNITY. REMOVING
DISCRETION AND PROGRAMMING
RESPONSES INTO OUR WORK
INSURERS ONLY A SHORT TERM
RESPONSE NOT A POSITIVE OUTCOME
IN A CASE. GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE.
WENT OVER A REASONABLE PERIOD
OF TIME YOU HAVE A CLIENT WHO
MIGHT COMMIT THREE TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS PROBATION LET'S CALL
IT A FAILED DRUG TESTS- FAILURE
TO SHOW UP TO THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT IN AB A FAILED
TREATMENT APPOINTMENT. BUT
THERE OTHERWISE COMMITTED TO-
LONG TERM REHABILITATION
PROGRAM THAT THEY'RE PERFORMING
WELL IN. THAT THEY ARE SHOWING
A DISTANCE IN THEIR BEHAVIOR IF
NOT- COMPLETE ABOLITION OF THE
NEGATIVE BEHAVIOR. IT NEEDS TO
BE LEFT TO THE DISCRETION OF
THE PROFESSIONALS AS TO WHAT TO
DO AFTER THAT THIRD TECHNICAL
VIOLATION OCCURS. AND PRESCRIBE
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
WHATSOEVER. PLEASE DON'T
MISUNDERSTAND FROM WHERE WE'RE
COMING. COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
SHOULD AVAIL OURSELVES OF ALL
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME IN THE
APPROPRIATE WAY. AT TIMES A
CUSTODIAL RESPONSES ABSOLUTELY
APPROPRIATE. IN FACT I WOULD
ARGUE AND RESEARCH SUPPORTS
THIS SOMETIMES A CUSTODIAL
RESPONSES APPROPRIATE AT THE
FIRST TECHNICAL VIOLATION. FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE A HIGH RISK
OFFENDER EARLY IN THEIR
SUPERVISION NOT YET POSSESSING
SOME THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
REMAIN CRIME FREE AND WHO
DELIVERS THAT SAME FAILED DRUG
TESTER THAT SAY MISSED
APPOINTMENT. YOU'RE DEALING
WITH A VERY DIFFERENT TYPE OF
PERSON AT THAT POINT IN THEIR
DEVELOPMENT. AND ALEX STILL
REAL SANCTION MAY BE THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE ON THAT
FIRST VIOLATION. BUT FOR MOST
EVENTS THIS IS SIMPLY NOT THE
CASE INDISCRETION SHOULD NEVER
BE TAKEN OUT OF THE HANDS OF
THE PROFESSIONALS WHO KNOW BEST
WHEN AND HOW TO EXERCISE IT. WE
USE THE DATA FROM ALL OF OUR
EVIDENCE BASED TOOLS AND
APPROACHES TO GUIDE OUR
DECISIONS INTERVENTIONS. MUCH
LIKE YOUR DOCTOR PRESCRIBES A
TYPE AND DOSAGE OF MEDICINE
BASED ON BEST PRACTICES. THEY
DO THAT IN CONCERT WITH PATIENT
SPECIFIC FACTORS. IF YOUR
DOCTOR SAID SHE WAS THE THIRD
TIME I'VE SEEN YOU IN MY OFFICE
WITH CHEST PAIN THE BOOK SAYS
WERE DOING SURGERY. AND EATING
CONSIDER ANY OTHER FACTORS IN
THAT DIAGNOSIS OR THAT.
TREATMENT INTERVENTION I WOULD
HIGHLY SUGGEST YOU FIND A NEW
DOCTOR. IT SHOULDN'T BE ANY
DIFFERENT WITH YOUR COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS OFFICIALS. IF
YOU'RE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
OFFICIALS ARE GOING TO THE BOOK
TO DETERMINE WHAT TO DO NEXT
RATHER THAN TAKING A LOOK AT
YOUR SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES.
THEN YOU SHOULD PROBABLY LET
ASKING FOR NEW PROBATION
OFFICER. PROBATION IS GUIDED BY
TOOLS AND PROFESSIONAL TRAINING
TO PROVIDE THE CORRECT TYPE AND
DOSAGE OF SANCTIONS SUPPORTS
INTERVENTIONS THE BEST ADDRESS
THE CRIMINAL GENIC FACTORS IN
SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES RELATED
TO OUR CLIENTS BUT ALSO LIKE IN
MEDICINE WE CAN SEE BASED ON
FACTORS RELATED TO THE SPECIFIC%
CASE WHEN THE APPLICATION OF
THE MOST COMMON INTERVENTION
IS. INDICATED IT IS THIS
ABILITY TO BE DISCREET AND OUR
INTERVENTIONS THAT GIVES US THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE
BEHAVIOR AND PURSUE OUR GOAL TO
BREAK THE CYCLE OF CRIME. WE'RE
NOT AWARE OF ANY EVIDENCE WHICH
SUPPORTS A COURT REVOCATION OR
OTHER PREDETERMINED SANCTION
AFTER THREE FOR ANY OTHER
NUMBER OF NON CRIMINAL
BEHAVIORS HAVING A LONG TERM
POSITIVE IMPACT AND COMMUNITY
SAFETY. UNFORTUNATELY THE
PROPOSED CHANGE IN THIS
INITIATIVE WOULD REMOVE THAT
DISCRETION WHERE IT'S NEEDED
MOST AND LONG TERM CHANGE
PROCESS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
OFFER SOME CONSIDERATIONS IS
REYES RELATES TO RETAIL THEFT
IMPROV FORTY SEVEN. SHE BALK
WAS NEUTRAL ON PROP FORTY
SEVEN- AS IT WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS. AS WE LOOK TODAY THE
MISDEMEANOR POPULATIONS BEING
REFERENCED IN THIS INITIATIVE
WE RECOGNIZE THERE ARE GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK FOR SOME
MISTER MINUTES PARTICULARLY
THOSE IDENTIFIED AS HIGH RISK
TO RE OFFEND. TO GET THEM
LINKED TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AND OTHER
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS TO
INFLUENCE BEHAVIOR CHANGE. AND
KEEP THEM FROM CYCLE IN IN AND
OUT OF THE SYSTEM AND POSSIBLY
ADVANCING ONE DAY TO FELONIOUS
BEHAVIOR. CURRENTLY MOST HONEST
MINUTES IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
RECEIVE ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES
AND SUPPORTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
THROUGH TODAY'S PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS. AS SUCH WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THIS TYPE OF
CONSIDERATION WE SUPPORTED PAST
EFFORTS SUCH AS AB TEN SIXTY
FIVE A CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER.
TO CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM FOR
HIGH RISK MISDEMEANOR
SUPERVISION ADDRESSING THE
TYPES OF FENCES OF THIS
INITIATIVE ALSO SEEKS TO
ADDRESS WE KNOW THAT OUR
APPROACH LIKE THE ONE PILOTED
WHEREBY RESOURCES SUPERVISION
BEST PRACTICES ARE LINKED TO A
TOGETHER WE WILL HAVE THE BEST
OUTCOMES IN ACHIEVING LASTING.
POSITIVE BEHAVIOR CHANGE. IT IS
OF PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE TO SEE
PARK THAT AS OUR LEARNING
INVOLVES AS OUR CONDITIONS
CHANGE WE CONTINUE TO EVOLVE
OUR SYSTEM OF CORRECTIONS. IT
IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT SEE PARK
THAT WE AVOID CHANGING OUR
SYSTEM ABSENCE SUPPORTIVE
INFORMATION TO GUIDE THAT
CHANGE. WE CONTINUE TO USE DATA
AND RESEARCH TO EVALUATE AND
BREAST EMBRACE CHANGES TO
ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY. WHICH
ULTIMATELY WE KNOW IS THE GOAL
THAT SHARED HERE BY EVERYONE
TODAY THANK YOU.THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR A OR
PROBATION CHIEF. UP GOOD SO- ON
A TWIN A- WHEN THE FIRST LAW
OFFERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS IT EVER GOT THEM TO
GO. I THOUGHT I WAS AN OUT OF
BODY EXPERIENCES ON. THOSE ARE
MY PEOPLE YES. SO I'VE I'VE
SAID MANY TIMES- THAT- WE
APPEAR MAKE LAWS BUT THE REAL
WORK IS AT THE CRACK AT THE AT
THE LEVEL THAT YOU'RE AT WHERE
PEOPLE HAVE TO IMPLEMENT THE
LAWS AND SO I'M GLAD YOU'RE
HERE BECAUSE WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WAS PROP FIFTY SEVEN-
FORTY SEVEN OR EVEN AB ONE OH
NINE WE PROBABLY NEEDED TO
PROBABLY CONSULT WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT. MORE AND YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M GOING. ABOUT WHAT
RESOURCES YOU NEEDED. SO THAT.
ALL OF THESE SWEEPING CHANGES
WHEN THEY'RE IMPLEMENTED THEY
WOULD BE GOOD SO NOW. MMHM I'M
GIVING YOU A OF BLANK CHECK
BOOK IN IF YOU COULD TELL US IF
WE FOR US TO MAKE ALL THOSE
CHANGES THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
NOW TO US SO THAT WE WOULD NEED
THESE PROPOSITIONS ARE WE WOULD
NEED ORGANIZED RETAIL STEP. BUT
IF WE COULD GIVE YOU ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU NEEDED TO BE
ABLE TO BETTER IMPLEMENT
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED TO DO-
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA ON A ON THE
STATE LEVEL LOCAL LEVEL. WHAT
WOULD YOU WOULD NEED OR IS THAT
TOO MUCH ONE A ONE TIME. I
WANNA LEGISLATOR ASKS YOU- WITH
A CHECKBOOK WHAT YOU WOULD DO
YOU ALWAYS BETTER COME PREPARED
WITH. MR CHAIRED I THINK THE
CITY PARK HAS A PRETTY- WELL
ESTABLISHED TRACK RECORD- OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS AT LEAST-
AND I'VE BEEN A PART OF THE
ORGANIZATION- FOR CLOSE TO
FIFTEEN YEARS NOW. AND I WORKED
IN SEVERAL JURISDICTIONS I'VE
I'VE WORKED IN AS SENATOR
SKATERS JURISDICTION ALAMEDA
COUNTY HAVE WORKED UP NORTH-
AND SHASTA COUNTY AND NOW HERE
NOW THE RATTLING SO I'VE SEEN A
VARIETY OF ASPECTS OF OUR
BUSINESS- THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT- PROBATION
HAS ADVANCED IN MY TWENTY TWO
ISSUE YEARS HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
LEAPS AND BOUNDS BECAUSE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- WHEN PROBLEMS
NEEDED TO BE SOLVED IN ALL
REFERENCE AB ONE OR NINE FIRST-
WHEN PROBLEMS NEEDED TO BE
SOLVED BIG HUGE. LIKE GROUND
SWELL CHANGING PROBLEMS- SHE
BOX BEEN THERE TO OFFER
SOLUTIONS AND THE SOLUTIONS OF
ALWAYS BEEN BASED AROUND
PREVENTING CRIME. NOT NOT-
INTERCEDING INACTIVE CRIMES
THAT'S NOT OUR PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY BUT BUT
PREVENTING THEM FROM HAPPENING
IN THE FUTURE AND THAT'S A LONG
TERM PROCESS. IT REQUIRES A LOT
OF EFFORT A LOT OF ENERGY IT'S
NOT JUST FROM PROBATION
OFFICERS IT'S A LOT OF ENERGY
FROM ALL OF OUR PARTNERS- IN
THE COMMUNITY TO PROVIDE A LOT
OF SERVICES TO PEOPLE FOR. DRUG
TREATMENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. I WOULD SAY THE ONE
OF THE FRESHER. THE I'D IS A
PROBATION CHIEF IS- ASKING MY
PROBATION OFFICERS TO ENSURE
THE PEOPLE ARE CONNECTED
RESOURCES THEY NEED ONLY TO
HAVE THEM COME BACK AND SAY
THOSE RESOURCES AREN'T IN OUR
COMMUNITY. A LOT OF SMALLER
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA DON'T
HAVE THE TYPES OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT SEE IN- SAN RANCISCO BAY
AREA LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO
AND HAND AND OTHER LARGE
JURISDICTIONS- SACRAMENTO IS
DOING. GREAT WORK WITH LOTS OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
THE PROBATION CHIEF THERE AND I
ARE GOOD FRIENDS AND I AM
JEALOUS OF SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HE HAS ACCESS TO. AND I'M
ONLY TWENTY FIVE MINUTES AWAY
BUT I DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SAME TYPES OF RESOURCES. SO
I'LL TELL YOU THE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE MORE OF IT IS COMMITTED
RESOURCES TOWARDS. LEAN CITY IN
IN COMMUNITIES WE HAVE THIS
MANTRA THAT- YOU CAN HAVE ALL
THE ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE WORLD
BUT WITH NO RESOURCES YOU CAN'T
MAKE IT STICK AND YOU CAN HAVE
ALL THE RESOURCES IN THE WORLD
BUT WITH NO ACCOUNTABILITY YOU
CAN'T MAKE THEM GO AND THAT
THAT REALLY IS THE BASIS OF OUR
WORK AT THAT THAT BALANCE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY OF STRUCTURE FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE HAD A LACK OF
STRUCTURE IN THEIR LIFE THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO- AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF AVAILABLE
RESOURCES BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO GET TO THEM. AND
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO STAY
INTACT WITH THEM OR THEY LET
ALLOW THEIR ADDICTION TO
INTERFERE WITH THEM CONTINUING
THROUGH. ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE WHAT. MAKE THE WORK IN
PROBATION SO VALUABLE IS WE CAN
PROVIDE THE STRUCTURE WE CAN
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE STABILITY- UNTIL
PEOPLE DEVELOP THEIR OWN. FOUR
REDEVELOP THEIR OWN IN SOME
CASES. AND THAT MEANS YOU YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A WELL FUNDED
PROBATION DEPARTMENT THAT'S GOT
PLENTY PROBATION OFFICERS THAT
WERE NOT JUST PROCESSING
NUMBERS BECAUSE WE GET TOO MANY
CASES. BUT YOU ALSO NEED WELL
FUNDED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND WELL FUNDED-
SUPPORTS IN DEPARTMENTS THAT
ARE THERE PROVIDING RESOURCES
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN MY COUNTY AND
I APOLOGIZE FOR GOING ON ABOUT
THIS BUT MY COUNTY. MY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT PROVIDES A
LOT OF THOSE- INTERVENTIONS. BY
PROBATION STAFF I HAVE TO HIRE
THE PEOPLE TRAIN THEM AND
PROVIDE THE SERVICES EITHER A
CLINICALLY- OR NON CLINICALLY
THROUGH MORAL RECOGNITION
THERAPY IN THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS WERE WE TRAIN PROBATION
OFFICERS TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
CLIENTS. AS COUNSELORS
ESSENTIALLY. AND A AND THAT'S
BEEN OUR SOLUTION BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF CEOS IN OUR
JURISDICTION THE CAN DO IT SO-
SO THAT'S WHAT I. WOULD SAY.
AND HAVE YOU KEPT- OR DOES YOUR
COUNTY KEEP STATISTICS ON CRIME
RATES SINCE. HERE IS TO HAVE A
LITTLE MORE OF A ROBUST.
REHABILITATION PROBATION.
OPERATION HAVE YOU KEPT
STATISTICS ON YOUR CRIME RATES
IN HOW IT'S BEEN IMPACTED YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SO- I MEAN EVERY
COMMUNITY KEEPS THEIR
STATISTICS ON CRIME RATES
BECAUSE THE REPORTER TO THE
STATE AND FEDERAL DOJ- AND I'VE
I'VE ACTUALLY. JUST LAST YEAR I
DID A FAIRLY IN DEPTHANALYSIS
BECAUSE I WAS HEARING SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE WERE HERE IN THE CRIME
WAS GOING THROUGH THE ROOF
SPECIFICALLY PROPERTY CRIME AND
I WANTED TO KNOW IF THAT WAS
TRUE MY COMMUNITY SO I PULLED
WERE REPORTED BY ALL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES IN MY
JURISDICTION- AND WHAT I FOUND
WAS. SIMPLY NOT ACCURATE WHAT I
FOUND WAS WAS TWO FOLD- THE
FIRST WAS- THAT PROPERTY
CRIMES- AT THERE ARE ALSO A
WHOLE LOT OF PROPERTY CRIMES
AND IF YOU POINT TO ONE
PROPERTY CRIME IT'S UP IN
ANOTHER PROPERTY CRIME IT'S
DOWN THE OVER ALL HIGH IMPACT
IS WHAT MOST PEOPLE QUOTE WHEN
THEY LOOK AT PROPERTY CRIME.
SOME PROPERTYCRIME WAS UP AUTO
THEFT FOR EXAMPLE AN AUTO
BURGLARIES UP SIGNIFICANTLY IN
MY COMMUNITY HOWEVER MOST OTHER
PROPERTY CRIMES WERE DOWN WHICH
LED TO AN OVERALL TREND OF
REDUCED PROPERTY CRIMES IN MY
COUNTY- SINCE FRANKLY
REALIGNMENT AND PROP FORTY
SEVEN THEY'RE JUST THERE
WEREN'T SIGNIFICAN INCREASED BY
PRIME ALL DOWN. NOW THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD NOTE IS WE
NEED TO LOOK WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE STATISTICS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT IN THE CONTEXT OF WE'RE
LOOKING AT HISTORICALLY LOW
CRIME RATES BY LOWER THAN SINCE
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES AND. I
WHEN YOU SEE A INCREASE IN
PROPERTY. TALKING IT NEED TO
LOOK AT. A FORTY YEAR TO. YOU
CAN'T JUST LOOK AT YEAR OVER
YEAR SAY WHAT THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WAS HIGHER THAN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. WELL YEAH IT WAS THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WAS AS LOW
AS NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. SO
LET'S PUT IT INTO THE CONTEXT
OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT OVER
THE LAST. WELL GENERATION.
REALLY AND WE WERE LOOKING AT
HISTORICALLY LOW CRIME RATES
AND I LOVE TO KEEP IN THERE. SB
FANTASTIC- THE REALITY IS WE'RE
GOINGTO SEE BLIPS IN CRIME
RATES. IT'S A CONTINUAL
DOWNWARD TREND OR STABILIZATION
OF CRIME RATES WERE WHERE
THEY'RE AT- BECAUSE THEY ARE AT
HISTORIC LOWS ROLES CAN HAVE
CRIME- BY I SUSPECT I WILL
ALWAYS BE EMPLOYED- HI. BUT
KEEPING THEM AT THE MODEST
RATES THAT WE'RE EXPERIENCING
NOW IS SUPER IMPORTANT THAT'S
NOT TO SAY THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE
CONSTITUENTS OF SENATOR
MORLOCKS REFERRING TO. ARE
HAVING ISSUES IN THEIR- POCKET
OF INTEREST. THOSE ISSUES ARE
REAL- AND WE THINK THERE ARE
WAYS TO ADDRESS THEM- FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN A REFERENCE TO MY
COMMENTS ABOUT HIGH RISK MISTER
MINUTES. THEY ARE REPEAT
OFFENDERS OR ARE HIGH RISK FOR
RECIDIVISM. AGAIN THEY DON'T
HAVE THE BENEFIT OF AVAILING
THEMSELVES OF PROBATION
SERVICES OF THAT STRUCTURE AND
THE SUPPORT AND ACCESS TO-
CLINICALLY BASED SERVICES.
WORTH PROVISIONS THE PATHWAY
FOR PEOPLE INVOLVED IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TO GET TO THINGS LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. AND
DRUG TREATMENT AND MORE
RECOGNITION THERAPY IN THOSE
OTHER TYPES OF COGNITIVE
RESTRUCTURING PROGRAMS. WELL
WE'RE THE PATHWAY TO THAT FOR
IN A LOT OF INSTANCES AND MAYBE
UNFORTUNATELY- BUT THE REALITY
IS WE ARE. AND IF WE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO A CERTAIN POPULATION
OF HIGH RISK OFFENDERS. BECAUSE
THEY KEEP BEING HIGH RISK BUT
UNDER NINE HUNDRED FIFTY BUCKS-
THAT THAT CAN BE A PROBLEM. AND
I JUST JUST AHEAD A QUICKLY
NOW. OF AND IT WAS A DISCUSSION
ON PRESENTED. YES HIGH RISK MR
MEANS YES AND WE- IN MY
COMMITTEE LOOKED AT. CERTAIN
CRIMES THAT WE POSSIBLY SHOULD
LOOK AT GETTING THEIR DNA SO WE
COULD TRACK THEM. WHEN LOT BUT
WE DIDN'T JUST IGNORE IT
BECAUSE MAYBE ONE THOSE THINGS
THAT HAD SLIPPED THROUGH PROP
FIFTY SEVEN AND FORTY SEVEN.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE PROBABLY COULD
HELP YOU. LAW ENFORCEMENT DO
YOUR JOB BETTER- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY- IT DIDN'T. TO
DATE. THE TO SAY THEY GOT THE
AUTOMATION CHANGES SAID
ULTIMATELY MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR TO A SIXTY- BUT THAT'S
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
LEGISLATURE. WORKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT- POSSIBLY COULD
HELP ON YOU WITH YOUR JOB DOING
IT BETTER IN A WAY THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE VOTERS
WANT AND WHAT THIS DOES
COMMITTEE WANT. TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. ANY OTHER A
YES SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MISTER CHAIRMAN-
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING
HERE EARLIER IN THE HEARING-
AND THANK YOU FOR SOME OF YOUR-
FINAL COMMENTS I THINK THAT
SOMETIMES WE- FIVE THERE ARE
CERTAIN. CHARACTERS AND
PERCEPTIONS OF TAKE ON A LIFE
OF THEIR OWN THAT AREN'T
NECESSARILY ACCURATE I KNOW
THAT EARLIER IN THE HEARING
THERE WAS A I THINK AROUND SOME
EXPLICIT REFERENCE MADE TO MY
OWN CITY OF. SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE AUTO BREAKING CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE AND I I'M I'M
ASSUMING THIS CAME UP BUT IT
DIDN'T. PROP 47-57 HAD NOTHING
TO DO- WITH AUTO BREAK INS IT
DIDN'T CHANGE- THE AUTO BREAK
AND STATUTES THERE WERE NOT
AUTO BREAK IN BALLOT MEASURES
AND SO I THINK SOME OF THIS
SORT OF GESTALT WELL THERE'S
WATER BREAKING PROBLEMS IN SAN
FRANCISCO NOW IN OTHER CITIES
AND THAT'S ALL THAT'S BECAUSE A
PROP 47-57 THAT IS. NOT
ACCURATE- WE HAVE AN ORDER
BREAKING PROBLEMS WERE ARE A
SOME PROGRESS AND STARTING TO.
STOP THE INCREASE AND EVEN
SLIGHTLY START TO BRING IT DOWN
TO REAL CHALLENGE AS REAL
IMPACTS IN MY CITY- BUT IT'S
NOT BECAUSE THE PROPERTY SEVEN
PROP FIFTY SEVEN- AND IN SAN
FRANCISCO PROPERTY CRIME HAS
BEEN GOING UP FOR ABOUT A
DECADE- IT STARTED BEFORE PROP
FORTY SEVEN AND BEFORE. PROP
FIFTY SEVEN- AND SO THERE ARE
OTHER FACTORS AT PLAY AND SO WE
CANCERS TIED- THE TWO TOGETHER
AND THEN I ALSO- AND AGAIN I
ASSUME THIS CAME UP EARLIER BUT
I. AM VERY FRUSTRATING THE MAN
THIS IS TRUE WHEN I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
ATTENDING A LOT OF COMMUNITY
MEETINGS ABOUT WITH THE POLICE
AND NOW YOU'RE UP HERE. THIS
NOTION THAT BECAUSE A FELONY IS
NOW A MISDEMEANOR THIS IS
NOTHING WE CAN DO ABOUT IT AND
THE POLICE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
AND WE HEAR THAT SOMETIMES A
COMMUNITY MEETINGS. BECAUSE A
PROPERTY SEVEN WE CAN ARREST
PEOPLE ANYMORE BECAUSE
SHOPLIFTING WAS LESS THAN NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS WE
CAN'T ARREST ANYONE ANYMORE AND
THAT IS NOT ACCURATE YOU CAN
ARREST SOMEONE. FOR MISDEMEANOR
YOU CAN SPEND SIX MONTHS OR
TWELVE MONTHS IN COUNTY JAIL ON
A MISDEMEANOR- I THINK WE AS A
STATE NEED TO DO BETTER AND
HAVING ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
MISDEMEANORS. AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS MUCH BROUGHT
IN THE POLICE US TO DO WITH THE
COURT SYSTEM PEOPLE'S BE A CAL.
FOR THE BEHAVIOR EVE IF IT IS A
MISTER BUT THE IDEA THAT YOU
CAN'T. ARREST OR PROSECUTE FOR
MISDEMEANOR- IS JUST NOT- IS
NOT ACCURATE SO I THINK WE
HAVE- THEY'RE- ALWAYS TO BETTER
AND I AGREE WITH THE CHAIR
THERE ARE THINGS WE CAN DO AND
WE SHOULD ALWAYS BE WILLING TO
TAKE A FRESH LOOK. BUT THE IDEA
THAT- THESE BALLOT MEASURES
HAVE SOMEHOW IN CAPACITY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I JUST DON'T THINK
IT'S ACCURATE SOME THANK YOU.
SO I THINK WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW. GOOD RIGHT PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT
PRESENTATION. THOSE WHO WANT
TO- PLEASE START PLEASE YOU MAY
BEGIN THE PERSON AT THE MY GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING MY NAME IS
LEAH SPELMAN I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PARTNERSHIPS FOR
TRAUMA RECOVERY A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION IN BERKELEY THAT
PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO
REFUGEES ASYLUM SEEKERS AND
OTHER INTERNATIONAL SURVIVORS
OF HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES. ET ARE
IS ONE OF FOURTEEN TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS OR TEARS SEES
THAT HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
THANKS TO THE EALLOCATION OF
SAVINGS FROM THE PASSAGE OF
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN. FOR
OUR ORGANIZATION A LOAN AN END
TO THIS FUNDING WOULD MEAN THAT
pFAR FEWER VICTIMS OF WAR
TORTURED GENDER BASED VIOLENCE
AND OTHER TYPES OF PERSECUTION
NOW LIVING IN THE BAY AREA
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
CARE THEY NEED TO HEAL. TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS LIKE P. T. R.
EXISTS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
UNDERSERVED CRIME VICTIMS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE FLAGSHIP TEARS THE
IN SAN FRANCISCO WAS INITIALLY
FOUNDED TO SERVE VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT. IN ORDER FOR
THESE CRIMES TO BE PROSECUTED
THEY FIRST MUST BE REPORTED
WHICH VICTIMS ARE OFTEN
RELUCTANT TO DO BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH LEVELS OF EMBARRASSMENT
FEAR AND TRAUMA. MENTAL HEALTH
CARE NOT ONLY SUPPORTS VICTIMS
WELLBEING BUT HAS OTHER
POSITIVE IMPACTS THE SAN
FRANCISCO TEARS THE FOUND THAT
WHEN CLIENTS RECEIVED MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. THE COOPERATION
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT INCREASED
BY FIFTY SIX PERCENT. A TRAUMA
INFORMED APPROACH TO JUSTICE
NOT ONLY SUPPORTS THE WELL
BEING OF VICTIMS BEGIN ALSO
HAVE POSITIVE WIDER RIPPLE
EFFECTS. I DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OUR STATE'S LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY POLICE
AND PROSECUTORS DO YOU TO
ANSWER THE CALL OF DUTY EVERY
DAY. I ALSO SHARE THE VALUE OF
CREATING SAFER COMMUNITIES AND
THE WAY TO DO THIS IS NOT TO
RELY MORE HEAVILY ON
INCARCERATION I'M THIS DOWN OF
I'M SORRY I MEAN INTERRUPT I
DID NOT OPEN THIS WITH THE
LIMITATIONS ON THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SO IF YOU COULD PLEASE
WRAP UP AND THEN ALL INDICATE
TO THE REST OF YOU. THIRTY TO
FORTY FIVE SECONDS WOULD BE
OPTIMAL BUT GO AHEAD AND WRAP
UP SOUNDS GOOD. AND THIS
DOWNSTREAM APPROACH FAILS TO
ADDRESS ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME OR
BREAK CYCLES OF VIOLENCE SEES
ARE ONLY JUST BEGINNING THIS
MODEL HAS BEEN EXPANDED ALREADY
AND OHIO ILLINOIS IOWA NEW
JERSEY AND GEORGIA. WE NEED
MORE TEARS SEES BUT THIS COULD
ALL BE ROLLED BACK DEPENDING ON
WHAT WE DO IN THE NEXT ELECTION
CYCLE THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT TO IT. HI GOOD MRNING MY
NAME IS GREGORY FIDEL AND WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE A PRISON
POLICY ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
CURRENTLY TWENTY ABOUT OVER
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND CURRENT
INCARCERATED MEMBERS AT ALL
THIRTY FIVE CALIFORNIA PRISONS-
I'M HERE TODAY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS TO THIS
INITIATIVE- I THINK ALL OF US
KNOW ANECDOTALLY DATA AND ALSO
THROUGH COMMON SENSE. THAT
THESE CRIME RATES ARE GOING
DOWN THINGS OF THIS NATURE. AND
WE KNOW THAT CORRELATION IS NOT
CAUSATION AND WE KNOW THE DATA
IS SUPPORTING. NOT WITH THIS
INITIATIVE IS PURPORTING TO PUT
FORWARD- HIGH DOSE OF
INCARCERATION ARE CREATING
THESE PROBLEMS THAT THEY'RE
SEEKING TO SOLVE- AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO SAY VOICE A STRONG
OPPOSITION- THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME THANK YOU. NEXT GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S TOM OFTEN I'M
A RETIRED DEPUTY CHIEF OF
POLICE FOR THE CITY WAS
SACRAMENTAL. THIRTY YEARS LAW
ENFORCEMENT CALIFORNIA. TWENTY
YEARS IN INGLEWOOD PT TEN IT
WAS SACK AND THEN. A LITTLE
OVER THREE YEARS AS A HEAD OF
STATE PAROLE. THE STATE PAROLE
EXPERIENCE CHANGED MY LIFE AND
CHANGE THE WAY I THINK ABOUT.
ESPECIALLY THE YOU GOT A
UNIVERSAL UTILITY OF A REST IN
OUR SOCIETY IS THE ANSWER TO
EVERYTHING THAT IRRITATES US
AND- THAT WERE AFRAID OF. THE
TRUE REALITY IS MISS ANDERSON
SAID AFTER THE FACT WE ARE VERY
MARGINALLY SUCCESSFUL IT TOOK.
CAPTURING PEOPLE PROSECUTING
THEM INCARCERATING THEM. THE
RATES FOR THE CRIMES IDENTIFIED
PROP FORTY SEVEN ONE LESS THAN
10% A YEAR. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
SELL PEOPLE ON A REALITY THAT
93% OF THE TIME WE FAIL IS THE
THING WE OUGHT TO BE PURSUING
MOST AGGRESSIVELY. I CAN'T
STRAWS ABOVE FOR STRONGLY
ENOUGH THE INCREASE IN RESPONSE
TO YOUR QUESTION SENATOR- AB
TEN SIXTY FIVE. I WAS HONORED I
INTERVIEWED BY A LARGE- DOT NET
BOB NEWS NETWORK YOUR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA A COUPLE MONTHS AGO-
THE WERE OF DOG RESPONDING TO
THE CALL CLAIMS BY THE LOCAL
POLICE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE THEFT CRIMES HAVE GONE OFF
THE MAP ESPECIALLY. FIFTHS OF A
RETAIL THEFT. AND I PUT IT UP
THE WITH THE TEN SIXTY FIVE WAS
ON THE BOOKS TO THE GOOD WORK
OF VIEW AND MANY OTHER. AND SHE
HAD NEVER HEARD OF THAT
NATIONAL GO BACK AND ASK YOUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS HOW
MANY CASES THEY'VE PRESENTED TO
THEIR D. AS FELONIES FOR THE
VERY THING THAT I THINK IS ONE
OF THE CORPORATE COMPLIANCE
ISSUES CONCERNS IN THE- THOSE
OPPOSE SUPPORT THIS INITIATIVE.
SHE THEN WENT TO ALL SEVEN
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHE'S ON FIVE CASES
HAVE BEEN FILED IN THAT. AB TO
ATTEND SIXTY FIVE SINCE ITS
INCEPTION AND AN ACTING IN
JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. LASTLY THE ABILITY OF
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
RESPOND TO NON VIOLENT CRIME
HAS BEEN A HANDICAP FOR FORTY
YEARS I PORTS PERSONALLY KNOW
OF. I THINK WE OFTEN AS A
SOCIETY AND POLITICIANS AND
OTHERS. ARE FOCUSED ON THE END
ALL RESULT HAS GOT TO BE A REST
HAS GOT TO BE INCARCERATION
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE CAN GET
THOSE GET TO WEAR IT MAKES ANY
SENSE. THAT SIMPLE IS IT
DOESN'T HOLD TRUE WITH THE FAX
THE ABILITY OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO RESPONDED NONVIOLENT CRIMES
AND JUST ASK YOUR CHIEF LET ME
SEE YOUR CALL MANAGEMENT ROVERS
PROP POLICY STATEMENT. THEIR
WAY LOW ON THE PRIORITY LIST
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE BECAUSE
WE NEED TO DEFAULT FOR VIOLENT
AND DANGEROUS CRIME FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE SYSTEM. THIS
PROBLEM WE HAVE TODAY THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. IT ISN'T
THAT DO YOU KNOW JESUS WOULD
JUST THROW MORE PORTAL IN
PRISON AND WE COULD JUST RUSTOM
BETTER WOULD ALL BE FINE NO THE
WHOLE DOGGONE SYSTEM IS MOTHER
TO DIS FUNCTIONALITY. THE END
RESULT THIS IS WHAT MY PAROLE
EXPERTS STRUCK ME THE END
RESULT THE PEOPLE THAT WE PUT
IN OUR JAILS AND PRISONS AND WE
PUT OUT EUROPE ROLAND AND
PROVISIONS. THAT'S A SYMPTOM
NOT THE BECAUSE YOU WANT YOUR
POLICE IS TO BUILD A GOLD OF
BOB PRIORITY CALLS YOU'RE GONNA
NEED TO PUT A WHOLE LOT MORE
THEM ON THE STREET I WAS THE
CHIEF. YOU MIGHT HAVE EIGHT OR
NINE PEOPLE OUT THERE ON ON THE
IN THE MIDDLE AND I DO PUT THEM
GOING TO. ROUSE BECAUSE SOMEONE
STOLE BALONEY ONE OF THEM READY
TO GO TO A VIOLENT CRIME OR
PEOPLE ARE INJURED IF YOU COULD
ROUTE PATTERSON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIVE WE- APPRECIATE
TEST I'D WANT TO PEOPLE OFF I
WOULD APPRECIATE BEING AS
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE I REPRESENT TWO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT LIKE TO SAY
SOMETHING BRIEFLY FOR EACH OF
THEM MY NAME'S GOING BACK AS AN
ON BEHALF OF DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE WHO OPPOSES THIS
INITIATIVE WILL POINT OUT THAT
COLLECTING THE DNA FROM DRUG
USERS SIMPLE DRUG POSSESSION
OFFENDERS IS A HUGE WASTE OF
RESOURCES. IT'S CROWDING THE
WOOD CROWDER OUR SYSTEM FOR
TESTING FOR RAPE KITS AND OTHER
EVIDENCE ALSO WITH A HUGE. AND
RACIALLY BIASED POLICY OF
COLLECTION OF PRIVATE MEDICAL
INFORMATION FROM CITIZENS. DRUG
OFFENDERS OVERWHELMING WHO
ARRESTED ARE BLACK AND LATINO
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE THEIR
MEDICAL INFORMATION THEIR MOST
PRIVATE MEDICAL INFORMATION
IT'S NOT JUST THE OFFENDER IS
THEIR KIDS IT'S THEIR PARENTS
IT'S THERE BECAUSE IN ITS
ENTIRE FAMILY TREES PRIVATE
MEDICAL INFORMATION AND PUT IN
A SO CALLED SECURE DATABASE.
THAT'S NOT SAFE IT'S NOT FAIR
IT'S NOT RIGHT. ALSO IN TERMS
OF. INVESTMENT IN DRUG
TREATMENT IN OUR COMMUNITIES IS
ABYSMAL. WE APPRECIATE THE
SMALL ROLE THAT PROBATION PLAYS
ON THE COURTS PLAY AN
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE IN THE
TREATMENT. BUT THE MAJORITY
DRUG USERS DO NOT COMMIT
PROPERTY CRIME A VIOLENT CRIME.
AND MAJORITY OF FAMILIES ARE
SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION ISSUES
ARE NOT ARE CRUEL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THEY NEED ACCESS
TREATMENT ON DEMAND. CALIFORNIA
UNITED HAVE NEVER INVESTED IN
TREATMENT ON DEMAND. BUT WE
INVEST IN COURT DIVERSION. LONG
FOR THE DURATION IT'S MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN LETTING PEOPLE
VOLUNTEER THEMSELVES TO GET
BETTER. ON BEHALF OF ELEVATOR
CENTER I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
ADDRESS THE MYTH THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GOING TOO FAR TOO
FAST. CALIFORNIA WITH FORTY
MILLION CITIZENS IF IT WERE
STANDALONE COUNTRY WOULD BE
AMONGST MOST INCARCERATED IN
THE WORLD. COMPARABLE WITH
RUSSIA AND BELARUS. OUR
INCARCERATION RATE IS THREE
TIMES THAT OF CANADA. AND FIVE
TIMES OUT OF ANY NORTHERN
EUROPEAN COUNTRY. AND NOT
BECAUSE NORTHERN EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES DON'T HAVE CAR BREAK
INS OR SHOPLIFTING OR BURGLARY
OR DRINKS. THEY DON'T OVER
PUNCH THEY DON'T KEEP PEOPLE
FOR RIDICULOUSLY LONG PERIODS
OF TIME. THEY INVEST IN PUBLIC
HEALTH AND COMMUNITIES THEY
INVEST IN JOB CREATION AND
THAT'S THE PATH TO SAFER
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS EDWARD
LITTLE I'M WITH CALIFORNIA'S
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS PRISON
SPENDING MEASURE. INSTEAD OF
SPENDING EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO INCARCERATE
AN INDIVIDUAL. WE SHOULD BE
TAKING THAT MONEY AND INVESTING
IT IN COMMUNITIES AND
EDUCATION. AND TREATMENT IN
MENTAL HEALTH AND FROM RECOVERY
CENTERS. WEEK TOGETHER CAN
INVEST IN SMART SOLUTIONS THAT
WILL CREATE THE SHARE SAFETY
THAT WE ALL DESIRE THANK. HELLO
MY NAME IS CHARLES STUART. AND
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF TIME
DONE IN MY ORGANIZATION SEE SEE
YA- I THINK WAS REALLY COOL
ABOUT THE SUBSTANCE BIG WITH
YOU GUYS- THE PROBATION OFFICER
TO CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
PACIFIC LEE APART AS MEASURE
WOULD AFFECT ME DIRECTLY I WENT
TO PRISON AND SEVENTEEN- AND-
BECAUSE OF REHABILITATION
OPPORTUNITIES IN PRISON THAT
REACHED THE CAME DOWN A
PIPELINE I BECAME A CERTIFIED
CHECK ABA COUNSELOR. AND HEY I
NOT BEEN GIVEN UP TO REBUILD TO
MYSELF ONE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THE FREEDOM TO COME OUT AND
MAKE SIMPLE MISTAKES THE PRO
VIOLATION- I WENT TO JAIL THREE
TIMES. STASHED AWAY FROM JOB
OPPORTUNITIES IN DIFFERENT
THINGS BECAUSE OF THE LAWS THAT
WERE IN PLACE I WOULD WIN BACK
TO PRISON. I THANK GOD THAT I
GOT ON TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE
LAWS BEFORE THAT WITH PAROLE I
WOULD HAVE BEEN BACK.
AUTOMATICALLY YEAR VIOLATIONS
ON THREE TIMES AND I WOULDN'T
BE HERE NOW AND SO I WANT TO
SAY THAT. THESE TYPE OF THINGS
ARE AFFECTING PEOPLE DIRECTLY
LIKE ME. AN THANK GOD I'M HERE
BECAUSE THE LAWS IN ADVANCEMENT
OF THE LAWS AND AYE AYE THAT'S
WHERE I'M LIKE I. I THANK GOD
FOR COMING TO SEE SEE WHEN I
DID. BECAUSE TWENTY YEARS AGO
LOWER KNOWS MY STORY WOULD BE.
BUT HERE I AM NOW TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK AND SAY. LIKE LET'S KEEP
GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TRANSLATE
THEM SO USE MY LOOK AT THIS.
THERE POLICY FAMILIA THERE'S
SOME JOAQUIN THE STOCKTON MY
NAME IS EASE MY ALLEN I AM FROM
FATHERS AND FAMILIES AND
STOCKTON. IMPLEMENT THE LAW WAS
AA PROPUESTAS DAILY A BUT ALAS
CUT BUT UP WE ARE LESS COURTESY
LEASE EQUALS THREE MOST BECAUSE
IT IS. SO IMPLEMENTING NEW
INITIATIVES TO EXPAND OUR
PRISONS. IS NAY CO ES A- NAY
GOT THE WALL A POOR KID KNOWS
IT DOESN'T SO CIERTAMENTE IS
WRONG AND IT'S NEGATIVE BECAUSE
IT SUCH AS BACK SOCIALLY. HEY
LOOK AT THE MOMENT THE
COMPLEMENT AND IT ALSO SETS
BACK CULTURALLY AND
EDUCATIONALLY. ACOSTA ROOM WAS
KIND OF A LEASE. OR CALL A
COURTESY BECAUSE YEAR. CLOSE TO
THE ONE ON THE WAY TO SEE THAT.
WHY NOT CLOSED PRISON AND FOR
EVERY THAT WE CLOSE DOWN WE
CREATE A NEW UNIVERSE. YEAH
YEAH. A LOS. AT A BUT AS ON THE
TOP MY- BUT OKAY A USE. ARE YOU
ON A LOCAL. THAT'LL SIX CONVICT
US. ARCHITECT HE SAID AIN'T
THERE IN ALASKA SEE THAT. AND
WHY NOT CHARMER COVER CENTERS
AS A HOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
CA. TO RE. THEM AND HE. THE CW
A PROPUESTAS GALAXIES THE IS
SIXTY OF US HE GET YOU ON THE
ECONOMY ON THE LIST. LASTING
THEY SEE IT THEY PUT IN PLACE
IT THEY THAT'S YES AND I. AND
HE'S IN APPROVAL FORTY SOME AND
FIFTY ENOUGH INITIAL. AGAINST.
GOOD MORNING MY IS JAY TORE I
AM WAY A SMALLER. BY THE NAME
OF JUSTICE FOR ENVISIONED I'M
ALSO HERE WITH A NUMBER OF
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED ARE.
INCLUDING BOSS CAL. FOR SAFE
AND JUST. OCCUR ALTHOUGH US ARE
NOT. AND I STE UP THIS THIS
PRISON SPENDING SCAM OF THE
MEASURE- AND- I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT. WE NEED TO KEEP PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO KEEP
IN OUR FATHERS AND OUR AND OUR
ROLE MODELS INSIDE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES NOT SEE INSIDE OF A
JAIL ELL OR PRISON CELL. A LOT
OF THESE CRIMES HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT OUR YOU KNOW
PROPERTY CRIMES ARE ECONOMIC
CRIMES WE NEED JOBS WE DON'T
NEED NO MORE JAILS ARE PRESENCE
THANK YOU. I'M MARGOT GEORGE
I'M HERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AN
ASSOCIATION OF FOUR THOUSAND. A
PUBLIC DEFENDERS PRIVATE
LAWYERS AND INVESTIGATORS. YOU
KNOW EVERY TIME I HEAR OF THE
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT'S BEING SPENT ON
INCARCERATING SOMEONE I JUST
THINK OF HOW MUCH BETTER. OUR
LIVES IN OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
FRIENDS LIVES WOULD BE IF WE
SPENT THE MONEY. ON MENTAL
HEALTH. SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
EDUCATION EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR YOU COULD SEND
SOMEBODY TO HARVARD FOR A YEAR.
LET'S PUT THE MONEY TO BETTER
USE WE WE'VE EMBARKED ON THIS
ROAD OF CHANGE IT IS NOT THE
TIME TO TURN AROUND THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON I'M ALSO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
INITIATIVE AS IT WILL TAKE US
BACKWARDS INSTEAD OF FORWARD.
HI MY NAME IS HER BROUGH SEKIAN
I REPRESENT INDIVISIBLE AND
SPECIFICALLY INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELLO HELLO MY NAME IS TEARS
STORED ON THE STATEIDE
DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA SAFETY
AND JUSTICE TIME DONE PROJECT.
IN A HOME FOR THE LAST YEAR
BOOK EVEN BEFORE THAT PROP
FORTY SEVEN. WAS THE OWN. WHAT
I FEEL IS THAT JAIL IS NOT THE
ANSWER A LOT OF TIME FOR PEOPLE
TRYING TO MAKE IT A OPPORTUNITY
AND LEADERSHIP IS THE KEY. ALLY
BY PROVIDING ALL THESE ON.
CONSEQUENCES IMPAIR YOUR THAT
YOU FACE AFTER A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION. HEY MAKES **** FOR
PEOPLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILY. AN ON I'M SAYING THAT
FROM EXPERIENCE. YOU KNOW I
WENT TO SCHOOL AND GOT MY
MASTER'S DEGREE AND EVEN THOUGH
MY MASTER'S DEGREE TAKES STILL
DENIED ME ALL TYPES OF HOUSING
AND JOBS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
IN LIFE. IT MAKES IT HARD FOR
PEOPLE WITH DAY TO DAY. EVEN
LIVE YOU KNOW SO WITH DESK
THERE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
PROPOSED INITIATIVE THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR
BRADFORD MY NAME IS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFTEN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA- WHICH
INCLUDES THE ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE ACLU OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THE ACLU OF SAN
DIEGO AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE FOR
A NUMBER OF REASONS. CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE GREAT STRIDES IN
REFORMING ITS CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM AND BEGINNING TO REVERSE
THE STATE'S SHAMEFUL HISTORY OF
MASS INCARCERATION WHEN THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED
PROPOSITIONS FORTY SEVEN AND
FIFTY SEVEN THEY VOTED TO
PROMOTE RACIAL JUSTICE. THEY
VOTED TO REUNITE FAMILIES AND
THEY VOTED TO- PROMOTE EIGHT
MORE RESPONSIBLE A SMARTER AND
A MORE THOUGHTFUL RESPONSE TO
MENTAL ILLNESS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND POVERTY. THIS MEASURE WILL
TAKE US IN THE WRONG DIRECTION
IT WILL TAKE US BACKWARDS IT
WILL DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND IT WILL COME
AT GREAT COST TO THE STATE BOTH
FINANCIALLY AND OTHERWISE FOR
ALL OF THESE EASONS WE ARE
EXTREMELY OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS WHEN IS MIGUEL GARCIA
POLICY COORDINATOR FOR THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COLLISION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
MEASURE LET'S REINVEST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU A MOMENT AGO BECAUSE SADDAM
FROM OAKLAND AND FROM
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR SOURCE
JUSTICE I'M SENIOR ORGANIZER
THERE- I'M DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
PROPERTY SEVEN- I WAS
SENTENCED- AT THE SIX YEAR OLD
TO LIFE IN PRISON. AND TO STAND
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY- BUT NOT
A YEAR AND A HALF- I'M A SINGLE
PARENT- IN OAKLAND AND- IN ALL
EVERY WASN'T FOR THE PROPERTY
SEVEN AT ENDED SHIFT. AND HOW
WE SEE PUBLIC SAFETY IN A AN
ARMED CALIFORNIA OUTS TO BE IN
PRISON TODAY- UNNECESSARILY I
FEEL BUT I WAS POSSIBLE PAROLE
ON MY FIRST INITIAL PRO
HEARING- AND WE CAN SPEAKING
TO. HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED I
KNOW THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAMS AND I STILL VOLUNTEER
MY TIME AND I ACTUALLY GO BACK
INTO PRISON EVERY MONTH TO
TEACH A CLASS. I'M NOT PAID FOR
THAT I DO IT ON MY OWN TIME-
BUT THE VALUE OF REHABILITATION
THE VALUE OF INVESTING IN. ARE
NOT DIVESTING FROM THIS ISSUE I
WAS VERY CRITICAL- AND TO HAVE
A VERY LARGE IMPACT IN
CALIFORNIA FOR YEARS TO COME-
SO I STRONGLY OPPOSES MEASURE
AND I COMPLETELY SUPPORT.
INVESTING IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN I'M SO ZERO NOW. I WORK AT
KURDS YOU KNOW FOR EASTER YOU
TO IN EAST OPEN BECAUSE- AND I
STRONGLY OF. THIS BILL BECAUSE-
HIS MEASURE. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT IF IN THE ABOUT HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND A KEEPER JOE BUT
NOT LOCKED UP IN JUVENILE HALL
A YEAR. MY OF THEM THE ELECTIVE
FROM. STILL CELL DRUGS YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING HAS TO DO WITH
POVERTY. AND WE'RE NOT ASKING
FOR ANYBODY TO DO SOMEBODY HOW
SEEING ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT
IF YOU GET PEOPLE OP FOR PEOPLE
JOBS THAT. CAN SUSTAIN THEIR
LIFESTYLES ARE LIVING
CONDITIONS PEOPLE WON'T FEEL
THE NEED TO COMMUNITY CROSS
OFFER LIKE. WE SHOULD INVEST IN
JOBS A COMMUNITY CENTERS THEY
OFFER HEALING SO THEY COULD
HEAR THEIR TRAUMAS. AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE THANK. HELLO
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS RECORD
WOMEN IN IN THE I WORK WITH
COURAGE IN EAST OAKLAND AND
NICE. OPPOSES BILL BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN OUT FOR ABOUT THREE AND A
HALF YEARS INTO. THIS AFFECTS
ME DIRECTLY BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE STILL AFFECTED BY
THIS AND ESTARá SO HARD TO
FIND LIKE EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
LIKE YOU KNOW RECORDS OF STUFF
LIKE THAT. THANK YOU. A GOOD
MORNING ONE AS THE AS MY NAME
IS DANNY MANDEL SO WE'RE
PROPOSING FAMILIES OF SULKING
BASIS STOCKED. AS AN AGENCY
THAT IS AN INTENTIONAL ABOUT
HIRING FORMING CARSON
INDIVIDUALS WE CONTINUE TO WE
HAVE SEEN CONTINUE TO SEE THAT
OUR COMMUNITY AND SOCIETIES BUT
ARE OFTEN WE EMPLOY THEM. WE
OFFER THEM HUMAN SERVICES WHEN
WE OFFER THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO YOU KNOW- GET BACK INTO
THEIR EDUCATION STUFF AND SO.
WE DO WE BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW-
TO RESOURCES AND OPPORTUNITIES
AND INVESTING IN OUR COMMUNITY.
IS FAR BETTER THAN JUST YOU
KNOW GIVEN THE MYSELF. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS GO TO
SUNDAY I'M A FOR. SADDAM A
SOMEWHAT. AND I. THE AND SHOP
RECOVERY CENTER. AS WE KNOW HER
PEOPLE HER OTHER PEOPLE AND WE
CAN EXPECT THAT TO CHANGE OF
WERE NOT. GIVEN THEM ACCESS TO
HEATING SERVICES. THE STOCKTON
TOM A RECOVERY CENTER PROVIDES
THAT ACCESS TO HEALING- AND
WE'RE ONLY ONE OUT OF. A ONE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND SO WE
NEED MORE EXPANSION LAST YEAR
SEE AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
INITIATIVE. GOOD MORNING BUT
KNOWS THE IS QUITE HONESTY MY
NAME IS TINA CARILLO ALLEN- I
ALSO WORK FOR FATHERS AND
FAMILIES OF SAN JOAQUIN. AS
SOMEONE WHO IS FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND ALSO A FORMER
HEROIN ADDICT. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS PRISON SPENDING
INITIATIVE. AND I AM VERY
FORTUNATE TO GET TO WORK FOR
THE SERGEANT FROM RECOVERY
CENTER. AND SEE FIRSTHAND WHAT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HEALING AND
DIGNITY LOOK LIKE. WHEN GIVEN
TO PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY-
VERSES. PUTTING PUTTING THEM IN
CELLS AND PRIORITIZING PROFIT
SO AM I STRONGLY OPPOSES
INITIATIVE AS WELL. GOOD
MORNING. MEDIA STILL GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS TONY
MACNEIL- I AM THE LEAD
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH FAITH
IN THE VALLEY AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY- AND WE MAKE UP
THE CENTRAL VALLEY- FOR FAITH
IN THE VALLEY ALL THE WAY
THROUGH KERN COUNTY- I AM ALSO-
AN ORGANIZER IN AFFILIATION
WITH PEOPLE CALIFORNIA I'M AND
I'M STANDING A REPRESENTS A
REPRESENTATION OF THEM AND WE
ARE ALSO DEEPLY- AFFILIATED
WITH FAITH IN ACTION ON A
NATIONAL LEVELAND I STANDING
REPRESENTATION OF THEM AND ALL
THE CLARITY. ON THAT WE WORK
WITH- AND THAT WE DID WORK WITH
AN ORGANIZED IN ORDER TO PASS
PROP FORTY SEVEN AND EDUCATE
THE COMMUNITY- SURROUNDING
47-57 AND HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
WORKING WITH THOSE THAT ARE
COMING THROUGH THE PENAL SYSTEM
THROUGH AB ONE ONLINE SERVICES
IN FUNDING- AND SO WE DO STAND
I SAY WE INTENTIONALLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THAT IS
BEING BY THE MEASURE THIS BE A
PROPOSED- I ALSO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- HAVE A RESEARCH
MEETING WITH PP I SEE- AND GO
OVER THE INFORMATION I'M SAYING
THAT INTENTIONALLY BECAUSE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I DID CATCH
IS AN OVERSIGHT AND I DID BRING
IT TO THEIR ATTENTION- AND THEY
DID SAY THAT THEY WILL. LOOK
INTO THAT- WAS I WANTED TO SEE
IF THERE WAS A CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE UP TAKES IN- IN
VANDALISM OR THE- LARCENY AND
BREAK INS WHEN HE CAME TO
HOUSING ISSUES AND
HOMELESSNESS- WITH A CAME TO
THAT POPULATION I DIDN'T SEE IT
ON THE DATA THE AND- SET THEY
WILL LOOK INTO IT AND SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT FOR
THOSE PLACES THAT HAVE THE
UPTAKE THAT THAT IS TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AND I'M SORRY THE
LAST VERY LAST SMALL THING I
WANT TO SAY. IS THAT WITH AN
ORGANIZER WE BRING INDIVIDUALS
AND THAT ARE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AND THAT ARE ON
THE ONES THAT WE ARE SPEAKING
OF FOUR WE BRING THEM IN AND
HELP THEM TO LEARN TO EXERCISE
THEIR VOICE. IN THE- AND ARE WE-
ARE EVER. THAT THIS IS A SIX
FOR THEM TO DO THAT AND THAT
THEY CAN TRUST THE SYSTEM AND
SO WHAT I AM ASKING IS THAT WE-
REPRESENT WHAT IT IS THAT THE
ORGANIZERS. ARE SAYING THAT
THEY CAN TRUST THE SYSTEM AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS LATOYA MAKE MAIL I AM HERE
THIS MORNING ON THE BEHALF OF
OR REPRESENTING FATHERS AND-FAMILIES OF SAN JOAQUIN-
SPECIFICALLY THE SECOND TIME OR
RECOVERY CENTER. AND IN THE
EVENINGS I VOLUNTEER MY TIME
WITH. FAITH IN THE VALLEY ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT SHE JUST TALK
ABOUT I AM HERE JUST TO SAY
THAT I STRONGLY OPPOSE. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF US PUTTING
MONEY BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY
SPECIFICALLY STOCKTON TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS. THEY ARE
NECESSARY THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AS A ABOUT
OWN ON BEHALF OF A FRIENDS
OUTSIDE WHERE THE LEAD IN-
ORGANIZER FOR ALL THE- YOU
CENTERS IN IN THE BUSINESS
CENTERS IN IT. CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPOSED HIS BILL NOT JUST FOR
MYSELF BUT AS A TAXPAYER. I DO
NOT AGREE WITH THIS THANK YOU
CAN. GOOD MORNING. SOME JAMES
SMITH FROM INSTITUTION WITH
OVER I'M- AQUATICA TAINTED
DIRECT. AND I'M ALSO WANTED
LADY SPOKE OF- WHERE DOES IT
COME FROM THE CONCRETE TO COME
FROM THE PRISON WALLS CITING
GAVE MY TWENTY YEARS TO THE
SYSTEM. I STRONGLY OPPOSES AND
YOU WERE SPEAKING EARLIER
CARDASSIAN ON. WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE ABOUT THE JOB SITUATION
AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT WOULD
WITH THE REHABILITATION FIRST
AND FOREMOST. THE
REHABILITATION INSIDE THE
PRISON WALLS YOU GO IN THERE
AND YOU GET CERTIFICATES YOU
CERTIFIED YOU'RE WORKING YOU'RE
WILDER'S. YOU WORKING FOR A
COMPANY THAT'S OUT HERE IN THE
FREE WORLD OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYINGTO WORK BACK TO GET BACK
TO YOU COME HOME YOU HAPPY YOU
GOT CERTIFICATES YOU GOT HELLA
WALL. YOU COME OUT AND GO
STRAIGHT TO THAT BUSINESS THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS MAKING SIX CENTS
AN HOUR TWELVE CENTS AN HOUR
AND THEY TELL YOU KNOW BECAUSE
YOU'RE A FELON. SO WHERE IS THE
REHABILITATION ACT WHEN YOU
TELL US TO DO THIS AND YOU GO
TO EVERYTHING THAT YOU SUPPOSED
TO DO AND IS DONE IS CERTIFIED
IS SPENT IN SIGN WHAT YOU COME
OUT IN A CLOSE THE DOOR WHEN
YOU THERE AS WERE ALL THE
HOMELESS IS THERE'S WHAT HE'S
OF THE CRIME JUST BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T TURN AWAY FROM THINGS
THAT YOU WORKED ON TO GET DONE.
THANK YOU. FOR HELLO MY NAME IS
CHARLOTTE ME AND I WERE WITH
BILL OPPORTUNITIES FOR SELF
SUFFICIENCY I WORK AS A PROGRAM
COORDINATOR CAREER TRAINING
EMPLOYMENT CENTER IN OAKLAND
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE- THIS
PRISON SPENDING INITIATIVE- AT
OUR COMMISSIONER WITH DIRECTLY
PLACE- INDIVIDUALS WERE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED ON
PROBATION AND PAROLE IN JOBS
THAT MANY SHOULD BE GOING TO
JOBS. HELLO MY NAME IS TO LEASE
SUMMERS AND I ALSO WORK FOR A
BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR SELF
SUFFICIENCY I AM A WORKFORCE
COORDINATOR- AS A PERSON WHO
IS. FORMALLY BEEN INCARCERATED
FOR FIVE AND A HALF YEARS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME TO TENURE
HOURS I AM ALSO A CASE RUN FROM
BOSS. I PULLED HIS BILL BUT I'D
LIKE TO OFFICES WELL. FOUR TWO
YEARS IN THE PENITENTIARY.
STAND ON A BUS TEN OR YARD ONE
DAY I HAVE SOME CASH IN WHICH A
BUS SAY. MRS CAREER OPPORTUNITY
TO LIVE RIGHT DOWN THE STREET
TO THE EVERYBODY AMERICA DOES
OCCUR OPPORTUNITY. BOOK IN
PRISON SYSTEM. WE GET TO
REHABILITATION SAYS THE COMING
TO PUT YOU BACK ON. WE CHANGED
IT UP WE HAD THEM COME IN WE
WILL REDUCE HOW YOU ARREST
PEOPLE WHO GO DROPPED A
THRESHOLD OF TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS. GAME RECOGNIZE GAME SO
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE DOING
WITH YOUR LORD OF MONEY DOWN TO
BE DOWN TO THAT MEANS YOU GO
WHAT ARREST MORE PEOPLE EVERY
STEP BUT WILL BE TATIAN HAD
ATTEMPTED TO REFORM. I GOT YOU.
MY NAME IS PAUL BRILEY ON THE
POLICY FELLOW WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
CHILDREN. I'M A STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS INITIATIVE
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO JUST TAKE
THE TURNS AWAY WE NEED AS MANY
SERVICES TO HELP TAKE THE PAIN
AWAY. HELLO MY NAME IS IN A ROW
AND I'M THE BOSS. AND I BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD TREAT OTHERS HOW
WE WANT TO BE TREATED WE SHOULD
NOT LOCK UP PEOPLE WHICH IS
FINE OTHER MEANS. CORRECTING
PEOPLE THEN LOCKING PEOPLE UP
IN CHINA PEOPLE UP. FROM ONE
LOVE FAMILY. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS ADAM I'M WITH- ICE YOU SEE
INLAND CORRUGATIONS UNITED FOR
CHANGE- WE ARE A FAITH BASED-
INTERFAITH COMMITTEE
ORGANIZATION IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE ALSO CONNECTED PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA AND FAITH IN ACTION
NATIONAL NETWORK THERE WERE
ALSO PART OF THE TIME DONE
MOVEMENT AND WE ARE AGAINST
THIS MEASURE- FOR A LOT OF THE
SAME THINGS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALLING- DOVES SAID THIS
IS- DRACONIAN. AND TREATS
PEOPLE LIKE DOGS MASS
INCARCERATION IS A SIN THAT
SPLITS APART FAMILIES AND
DESTROYS LIVES AND WE NEED TO
WORK ON HEALING THAT NOT
CREATING MORE PROBLEMS THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
CENTER EASE SOME. ON THE
FOUNDER OF TRUMP TO THE TRAUMA
pAROUND A BUILDING COMMUNITY. AT
FEWER BROKEN COMMUNITY SOME
AWESOME OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION OF FOUNDER OF SELF
AWARENESS OF RECOVERY A FORMER
EMPLOYEE OF THE TRAUMA RECOVERY
CENTER ALL OUR FOLKS OF FATHERS
OF FAMILIES A SOMEWHAT KING-
AND CURRENTLYWORKING WITH ALL
OF US ARE KNOWN AS A SENIOR
STAFF ORGANIZER HIM SACRAMENTAL.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL I BELIEVE IT
IS FAR TOO MUCH MONEY ALREADY
BEING INVESTED PROBATION IN
SACRAMENTO FRANCIS GATTI A
MILLION DOLLARS. OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE ONLY GOT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND THE COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATION WE GOT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH%
A LAUNDRY LIST OF EXPECTATIONS
OF A WE ARE EXPECTED TO DO WE
CANNOT VOLUNTEER WAIT. WHAT
THIS PROBLEM WE NEED MORE
FUNDING WE NEED MORE RESOURCES
I'M CONSTANTLY WORKING NIGHTS
IN A LOT OF VOLUNTEERS AND
THERE'S NO MONEY FOR US IT AND
WE'RE JUST.SPENDING GAS
SPENDING TIME SPENDING ENERGY
TRYING TO HELP OUR YOUTH WITH
IT WOULD KEEP HIM AT A JUVENILE
HALL IS A WORKING WITH FAMILIES
WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WHEN-
LEVELS ARE INCARCERATED. PEOPLE
COMING HOME- YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
DRUG ADDICTION ISSUES I'VE DONE
HEALING PRACTICES WTH MEN AND
WHO SOCIETY CONSIDER MURDERS IN
CRIMINALS AND OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED MAN I'VE WORKED IN
HEALING SPACES AND FACILITATED
HEALING AROUND AND MOST OF
THEM. ARE IS FOOD ON TWO THINGS
POVERTY IN TRAUMA. SO WHEN YOU
MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO PROCESS
THAT TRAUMA THAT PAIN FROM
PEOPLE WHO'VE COME FROM THAT
BACKGROUND WHO UNDERSTAND THE
BACKGROUND NOT FROM PEOPLE
WHO'VE NEVER LIVED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WOULD NEVER
UNDERSTOOD OUR STRUGGLES. WHO
CANNOT RELATE WITH THE CULTURAL
BARRIERS PEOPLE THAT REALLY
UNDERSTAND WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES IN RIGHT THEREFORE I
REALLY WANNA PULLS AT THIS BILL
AND- I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD
GOOD MORNING. LET ME TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF MY NAME IS
BROACH HI I'M IN AND BACK FOR A
AN AGENCY CALLED- BOSS- BOSS IS
AN ACRONYM FOR BUILDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SELF
SUFFICIENCY LOCATED IN- OPEN
AND AN OPEN AND BERKELEY AREA I
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS
INITIATIVE. BASED ON MANY OF
YOU STATED THAT ARE YOU HAD YOU
PUT SOME INK ON AB ONE OH NINE
AND SOME DID RIGHT. I AM I WAKE
UP EVERY MORNING AND I GO TO
SLEEP EVERY NIGHT AND I THINK-
FOR- MY WIFE MY CHILDREN. AND
THE HISTORICAL LEGISLATION OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH NINE I AM
A PRODUCT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
OH NINE DUE TO THAT HISTORICAL
LEGISLATION I WAS ALLOWED TO
COME HOME AS A PARTICIPANT IN
BE PRO AFFORDED THE SERVICES OF
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER- ACCESS
AND- AS FROM A PARTICIPANT IN A
PROGRAM AT BALLS I HAVE WORKED
MY WAY UP AND NOW I AM THE
MANAGER OF RE ENTRY SERVICES SO
I BELIEVE THAT THESE DOLLARS
SHOULD BE. USED TO REFORM
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM- AND
REHABILITATION- I HAVE A WHOLE
BUNCH I WANT TO SAY RIGHT BUT-
SENATE SKINNER CENTER SENATORS
DINNER PUT ME ON A TIME FRAME
SO. I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR PROVIDING ME THE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
THOUGHTS. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS OLIVER WIDOW. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO DO SOME MEASURE. THE
REASON IS BECAUSE I'VE BEEN OF
FORTY SEVEN. LIKE I YES- MY
SKETCHES VENUS POLISHED.
THEY'RE NOT IS IT FEEL FREE. IS
A SECOND SHOWS THE EVERYBODY TO
SERVE. I'M OUR INVOLVED IN A
SPECIAL OCCASION. AND THE
REASON IS THAT- OR KIDS ARE
BEING PUNISHED FOR LITTLE
MISTAKES. AND LIKE I SAID
SECOND CHANCE THE REST IS THE
SERVER SO EVERYBODY. WE HAVE TO
START GIVEN OP PROGRAM FOR KIDS.
BECAUSE WHEN THEY COME OUT OF
JAIL THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN
RECEIVE TREATMENT IS GOING BUT
THE WOULD YELL AGAIN. BECAUSE
OUTSIDE WITH THEM GET ANYTHING.
SO PLEASE. KEEP WORKING WITH
PRO FREE SEVEN FM IMPROV OF
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS DAYS ON DALE AND I'M A
PARTICIPANT A BUS AND I OPPOSE
THE PRISONS CARE. BECAUSE I-
DON'T BELIEVE IN IT ACTUALLY NO
TO ACTUALLY NO- THAT TO MAKE
MONEY OFF OF PEOPLE BEING IN
PRISON. SOME PEOPLE ACT. FACE
UP TO THIRTY YEARS IN PRISON
THEY- WORK. THEY MAKE MONEY
WORKING IN THE PRISONS AND THE
PRISONS COULD BORROW. THIRTY
BAKER BORROW UP TO. AS MUCH
MONEY THAT THEY MAKE FOR THIRTY
YEARS THAT THEY WORK. SO I
ASKED WHY I'M AGAINST IT YOU
KNOW. WE CAN USE THAT MONEY FOR
SOME ELSE. BECAUSE OF THE LAST
ONE RIGHT. OF MOST WANTED THANK
YOU SENATOR BROWN PERSONAL
SKINNER AND DINNER JONES SAWYER
FOR- PUTTING THIS ON- YOU KNOW
ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE- AND THE PEOPLE SHOWED
UP. RIGHT YOU KNOW AND JUST
TOOK. THE ONE RESPOND TO
SOMETHING THAT- A COLUMN IN LOS
ANGELES AND THE FOX ELEVEN IS
RUNNING THE THAT- AND THE
STORIES AROUND YOU KNOW- MATH
MAY HM ON THE STREETS OF LOS
ANGELES AMONG THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND HOW THE DRUG
CARTELS ARE- SUPPLYING THIS
MESS. AND HOW PROP FORTY SEVEN
IS ENABLING THEM RIGHT OFF THE
TOP A NARRATIVE THAT IS TRULY
TRULY HE A REPRESENTATION OF
WHAT OF STRUCTURAL
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM LOOKS
LIKE. RIGHT A YEAR A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO YOUR THE OPIOID CRISIS
IN OUR COUNTRY AND THE RESPONSE
WAS WE NEED MORE WE NEED MORE-
ADDICTION COUNSELORS WE NEED
MORE SERVICES BUT AS SOON AS
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE ANIMALS
VERBAL STATE LIVING ON THE
STREETS THE BURSTING BUT THEY
SAY THE LOCK US UP. RIGHT AND
THIS INITIATIVE REPRESENTS STAT
A REP IT REPRESENTS THE WORST
PART OF THIS COUNTRY WITH HIS
RACISM RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS THE PRISON SPENDING
SCAM AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS CAMP. THANK
YOU. LESS LAST. JACK WITH
INITIATE THIS I WENT TO A
BUDGET HEARING MEETING A COUPLE
MONTHS BACK IN SAN DIEGO. AND
THEY MENTIONED HOW IT WOULD
COST SEVEN HUNDRED MILLIONS FOR
THE RECONSTRUCTION OF ONE
PRISON AND I JUST FEEL LIKE
THAT MONEY SHOULD BE GOING
TOWARDS. LIKE THE RESOURCES
THAT THE CHEAPER PROBATION WAS
SPEAKING ABOUT AND OTHER
PROGRAMS AND CENTERS. THAT WE
COULD USE IN THE COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING AND PARTICIPATING AND
FOR SUPPRESSING YOUR VIEWS AND
FOR EDUCATING US ON WHAT SOME
OF YOU WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
SERVICES THAT YOU'RE PROVIDING
WHAT SOME OF YOU WHO. WERE
INCARCERATED NOW DOING WITH
YOUR LIVES AND WHAT THE VERY
SERVICES THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED EITHER HELPED OR DIDN'T
HELP EITHER. I REMEMBER WHEN I
WAS A IN THE ASSEMBLY I GOT IT
ELECTED EIGHT. MY FIRST. DAISY
FIVE YEARS ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. WE WHILE WE HEARD
OBVIOUSLY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND WE HEARD FROM ADVOCACY
GROUPS WE RARELY RARELY SAW
FOLKS WHO WERE SYSTEM IMPACTED
WHO CAME TO OUR HEARINGS AND
EXPRESSED ANYTHING ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES WE ARE RECEIVING
MUCH MORE OF THAT NOW I THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US-
IN TERMS OF OUR- DELIBERATIONS
IN OUR ABILITY TO DEVELOP THE
APPROPRIATE POLICY IN THE
APPROPRIATE BUDGET ACTIONS. AND
I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
THANKS TO YOU ALL FOR BEING
PRESENT FOR ENGAGING WITH US
AND HELPING US- YES. AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR-
HANGING IN THERE FOR THE
HEARING AND IF ANY OF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE CLOSING COMMENTS-
GO AHEAD CENTER REDFORD. YES
SOMEONE THANK BOTH CHURCH
CURRENT JUROR JONES SAWYER FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR ALL THE
WITNESSES WHO'VE COME OUT. AND
CHARGER STORY BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT AND FAR TOO OFTEN WE
AS LEGISLATORS THINK WE HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS AND WE TRY TO.
LEGISLATE FROM THE VACUUM BUT
IT'S TRULY THE REAL LIFE
STORIES A HELPED SHAPE MY
DECISIONS AND HOPEFULLY SHAPES
OUR COLLEAGUES DECISIONS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. AND I THINK ONE
OF THE LAST WITH THIS IS
CLEARLY SHE SPOKE TO THE ISSUE
THIS IS DEEPLY ROOTED IN RACE.
AND EVERYTHING THAT IS HORRIBLE
IN THIS COUNTRY IS THAT THE
RACISM IS AT THE BEDROCK OF WAR.
WE ARE AS A NATION WE NEED TO
ALL NOW. BUT I HOLD THE PRINT.
OF THIS MEASURE. WALKED I THE
BULLS ARE THE ONESWHO REALLY
NEED TO HEAR THIS BECAUSE IT'S
COLD THERE CLUELESS ASKED TO
WHY THEY FEEL THIS IS NECESSARY
AND THE FALSE NARRATIVES OF
CRIME IS INCREASED AND
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THIS NATION
HAS BEEN TO BOX MOST
IMPORTANTLY BY THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER WHO CLEARLY I
THINK WAS TELLING AND IF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN HERE THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
LISTENING TO BUT AGAIN I THINK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
YOUR STORIES MOST IMPORTANTLY
YOUR COMMITMENT AND YOUR
PASSION. TO HELPING US FIX A
SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN LONG LONG
BROKEN IN THIS COUNTRY SINCE
THE THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT AND
THE ENDING OF SLAVERY SO THANK
YOU. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
PERSONALLY THANK THE PANEL. FOR
THEIR TO THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
AND DISCUSSION ON THIS
INITIATIVE- MEATBALL TO YOU
KNOW TO THE- THAT THE FUTURE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEM IS ONE OF
MY MAIN LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
ARE AND IS OBVIOUSLY OF
INTEREST TO OF A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS. IS IN THAT SPIRIT
THAT WE WELCOME TODAY'S
DISCUSSION. IN ADVANCE OF THIS
MEASURE BEING PLACED BEFORE THE
VOTERS. THANK YOU TO EVERY
ATTENDEE FOR BEING HERE IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
THE ISSUES THAT AFFECT
THEMSELVES THEIR FAMILIES OR
THEIR COMMUNITY THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU IN WITH THAT WE WILL
CONCLUDE OUR JOINT ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEES
HEARING ON THE PROPOSED
INITIATIVE. PRESIDENT ALL RIGHT.